[Music]
uh
up
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
um
i know it's wrong
but i don't care
[Music]
the fire is strong
but i don't care
[Music]
for is eyes
think about it later
[Music]
all i ever
is
[Music]
[Applause]
think about it later
[Music]
is
as the world entered an unprecedented
crisis magnus carlson and chess 24 acted
quickly to create the first online chess
tour of its kind working 24 7 we brought
together the best players in the world
for the largest online prize fund ever
we have an opportunity to play online
tournaments and while
other sportsmans are basically doing
nothing
chess players can can play the
tournaments and as a chess player as a
top player i need to be able to compete
against strong players regularly
otherwise i'd lose my strength and get
rusty
so in this regard i'm very grateful to
have high level
competitions and
it's not
sometimes it's not even about the money
but sometimes it's about the way the
players are treated
and the opportunity to be able to play
against the strong and top grand masters
regularly in a serious event
and so in that regard i'm i'm very happy
that this is happening
broadcast live in 10 languages the tour
innovated and filled the void created by
the lack of in-person play reaching more
people than any online chess event ever
good luck to chess 24 and
you are all on a right way to organize
such a great tournament
there was fun and laughter oh my gosh
what a gorgeous square queen e5 is
to my mind this queen on e5 is like a
goddess
it's perfect
as you as you're showing
it's a it's an absolute pin on the rook
there's a pin on the queen
uh talk about you know dark square
domination against the bishop on b1
which is a light square piece
this is
the this is a dream move
there was tension and controversy what a
game
oh
whoa and magnus gave up his bishop with
the move rook a
a peter
yeah this is
this is uh already something i mean an
indication that something went wrong
yeah for magnusia he miscalculated he
missed maybe maybe not miscalculated he
just blundered this bishop takes a five
idea you know you you put the bishop on
a square
uh-oh but hang on h4 queen e8 did
queen a8
that's a turnaround move
oh my goodness queen a8 rook a1 queen h1
made peter
ding blundered terribly
they were instructive learning moments
we have discovered uh e6 was a very
strong move for neapolis she opens up
the diagonal of the queen and at the
same time shots out the d5 bishop from
the defense black has to play rookie
seven to protect the corn and the
seventh rank but now the queen comes
from the f5 queen f2 threatening rook
have seven and its curtains so the
position is collapsing right now here
black has to resign and there was lots
of great chairs
oh wow wow it's really
an incredible game like showing how a
completely lost position
can gradually turn into a winning
position if you just trade all the right
pieces it's really this game is really a
master class on on the trades what you
should be trading and what not and when
i said that
trading the queens and the bishops uh is
good for black i never imagined it would
ever happen because it's just it was so
far away from that
[Music]
wow resignation from dingley right
i find the games very exciting actually
the knockout stage is very exciting
four unique online events and a grand
final made up the magnus carlson chess
tour and the world took notice
[Music]
the magnus carlsen chess tour has been
the most watched online chess event in
history already it has become the
world's most prestigious series of
online tournaments as the first season
approaches its conclusion we want your
help to do something even bigger our
partner for the tour final is kiva the
non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help under-served
communities kiva does incredible work
providing micro loans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covit 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world
chess has helped me a lot
it's my job career
and it also makes me who i am now
in this difficult period
the magnus carlsen chester has provided
me
with opportunities to
play and compete
and it also brings company and joy to
the chess fans
in addition i joined the
cuba campaign
in order to helping help to help
companies
affected by the epidemic
chess24 wants to help make that happen
during the tours final we will be
donating 50 of all proceeds from new
premium memberships to kiva go premium
and you will not just be supporting us
and getting the best chess entertainment
out there you will be supporting people
in times of need through kiva and if you
are premium already you can buy
sponsored premium memberships for
schools in cities and countries of your
choice in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
together
[Music]
so
all of a sudden after h4
magnus felt like aha let me use the
chance i'm even getting a better version
compared to the previous game but knight
e6 runs into knight xc5 and knight d4 is
not possible because of this wonderful
tactics with knight f7 which just wins
the game on the spot
thanks to king takes f7 queen h5 check
the terrible disaster for the world
champion magnus has to win on demand
[Music]
oh well
no there's knight takes g4 okay now it's
a dead draw
[Music]
no but nobody likes the french i also
didn't like the french but like the
course
makes it great because like it's a
sharpening but with
i've done so much work
to make it actually kind of first of all
correct
like
basically correct also like fun i mean
i'm making like i basically recreate
like i take this crappy french and make
something great out of it
[Applause]
hello and welcome to chess 24 this is
the magnus carlson chess store
benefiting kiva finals and we are at the
halfway mark as we go into
set four this is the best of seven which
means the first player to win four sets
wins the magnus carlson chess store 22
and each set consists of four rapid
games in case of a tie let's get let's
get that on the screen so the format is
each set with four rapid games and in
case of a tie we have got two blitz
games and in case that's a tie as well
we move on to the armageddon going into
set four it is hikaru nakamura who has
taken the lead in this final he leads
the match with a 2-1
set lead he won the first uh the first
set magnus carlson bounced back and then
yesterday was again a hikaru nakamura
show what a final we've had so far
absolutely explosive the chess has been
incredible the drama has been non-stop
we've been on the edge of our seats
truly a dream
final
yesterday was uh
i think it left so many of us absolutely
speechless because man is hikaru in form
and is he killing it or what i want to
take you through some of the critical uh
critical moments that we had
yesterday let me quickly try and bring
that up
uh game one of course magnus played
flawlessly and i think that was the
first time that we felt in this final
that
magnus uh we were seeing glimpses of the
world champ as the world champion it
seemed like he almost outplayed uh
hikaru with with excellent technique
playing quickly just just a brilliant
play by magnus but where i want to get
you is
game two and game two was actually just
a berlin job we've seen that drama we've
seen that narrative again and again uh
let's
we're gonna get back to that but before
that let's go straight to game three in
which hikaru struck back to level the
score with really strong opening prep
and the point i want to bring up is
where did magnus go all wrong and it was
right around here
h4h5 was a new idea by hikaru it was
something that he had prepped for this
round and it took the world champion by
surprise but he it seemed as if magnus
had it all in control until this very
moment very uncharacteristically after
a4 right here and this is the critical
moment the world champ takes seven and a
half minutes and makes a move
he goes before here and i think this
just was something that took all of us
by surprise and we also had hikaru talk
about this that he was he was taken
aback by this decision
of magnus carlsen where he just fixes
his pawn structure in this very
undesirable way
and uh eventually after this i think
hikaru just played
brilliantly he traded off all the pieces
went into into an end game of opposite
color bishop and took advantage of the
spawn structure with the pawns fixed on
a5 b4 e5 c7 with his dark squad bishop
the other moment was king f7 in this
game let's quickly bring that up
and right about here the world champion
again surprised us because clearly in
this ending black's only chance is to
keep the rooks alive if if the heavy
pieces also the very last heavy piece
gets traded off white has a clear
advantage of winning end game because
take a look at the pawn structure
black's bishop cannot get to any of
white spawns while white's bishop grabs
everything and won the house
game four was
was just absolutely fabulous to see
because magnus
it looks like magnus was about to have a
have a victory there he played extremely
well put pressure on hikaru but hikaru
showed that he's not just an incredible
aggressive and fearless player who plays
really fast but he's also damn good at
defensive chess he showed some
incredible defensive resource in this
entire game very instructive and it was
really nice to hear hikaru say that he
found this as the highlight of
yesterday's set and it's true because
defending such positions against magnus
is
no easy task it's not a joke we've seen
the best in the world falter doing that
but hikaru nakamura with the form he's
showing with the shape he's in was
definitely up to task and then we had
the blitz action with the matches thai
with the games tied two two we went into
blitz and the game won it was just
absolutely shocking to see what happened
here because the world champion in a
well-known position went knight to e6
just giving up uh giving up the pawn
here and uh
definitely we saw we're gonna try and
bring up
uh magnus's expression right around here
because even though this position has
been played before
it was not his intention and let's see
if we can play that video which showed
exactly how disappointed magnus was with
this slip
and we can see the world champ here
reacting to what he's just done on the
board knight e6 just picked up the e5
pawn and there you see it even though
this position has been paid before it
was definitely not on magnus's agenda
which was made very clear on the camp
and as hikaru pointed out it's been a
long tour it's been many many games
these things happened blunders happen
and uh it's not something i have no
doubts that magnus carlsen is not it's
not that he's not aware of the fact that
knight d4 here doesn't work tonight f7
king f7 queen h5
but actually just a a mix-up in the
opening
and then we went on to second blitz game
which was a win-on-demand situation for
the world champion and man he played
well he created his chances he played
this uh this reverse dragon english
setup and made something out of nothing
he put pressure on hikaru and it looked
like magnus was about to level the score
and
just
it was incredible to see because with
five minutes and three seconds and both
these players playing on just minutes
uh magnus continuously putting pressure
on hikaru hikaru just holding on
managed to survive yet again with
tremendous defensive skills and i think
the one thing that really stood out
yesterday and came to light was that
indeed hikaru is not just a very strong
combative player but has got immense
defensive resources up his skill and
that is something that against the world
champion has been a big challenge for
everybody uh this match this match
wrapped up with this blitz game and
magnus carlsen was not really able to
make anything out of the of the extra
pawn that he won in the middle game
because the pieces got traded off take a
look at how things ended at this moment
[Music]
this was the very end of the position
and we see everything gets traded off
it's
and there you have it magnus just
not
happy with how things went and i think
i think this was
again very uncharacteristic of magnus
because we have seen him
be able to make something out of
seemingly nothing positions but in this
match whether it was this game or game 4
where he was clearly better hikaru was
definitely up to the task and despite
magnus posing big questions on the board
hikaru solved all of them and magnus i
think very rarely we've seen him not be
able to convert such
uh such positions we had a really
insightful interview with hikaru and i
think it was very
very interesting to hear his take on
magnus and how the finals have shaped up
so far take a look at this in some ways
i think winning in ledous kind of broke
out that streak in a way because i
started to realize that i can play
against magnus or play on the same level
and um we'll see what happens but i i
would i'm being honest i think i've
already exceeded my expectations so now
i'm just going to keep trying to to go
from here and uh and and keep putting
pressure on magnus on the remaining
matches my car you're being very modest
because we all know
right i think we are
probably going to just um
yes so that was uh hikaru nakamura on
how the final has gone uh we might play
that again in a bit we're just trying to
fix a little bit of a sound issue in
that video but i think it was really
fascinating to hear
hikaru
talk about
show actually both these players have
shown immense respect for each other
throughout the match uh throughout this
final before the start magnus spoke
about how hikaru has been so informed
and it's definitely going to be a tough
final for him hikaru in yesterday's
interview also uh also mentioned just
just acknowledging the fact that yes
magnus carlsen is the best player in the
world but it's a huge confidence boost
for him to see that he's playing at par
with him if not better specifically in
this final i think i think on paper
uh magnus carlsen is a clear favorite in
this final but the way the games are
going and on board he's becoming a less
and less of a favorite as the final is
progressing because even the set that
magnus won on day two
was in many ways
hikaru was the better player that day
and
i think
i think he really held his own and at no
point have you felt that
magnus has been dominating the final
like we've seen him do that in this
store over and over again but obviously
a lot of money at stake here so the
world champion has to bounce back
because i do not believe if hikaru takes
a two set lead
i think that's going to be extremely
difficult to come back from because at
the end of it uh the margins are getting
uh lesser and lesser the the sets are
getting fewer and fewer and if uh if
hikaru nakamura was to do what he's been
doing this entire final so far magnus is
up for a really really uh tough time so
a big day for the world champions he's
definitely
definitely recover definitely looking at
uh at a strike back today the prize fund
of course the winner of the final goes
back with a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars while the runner-up will go back
with
uh with eighty thousand dollars so a lot
of money at stake a lot of pride at
stake and this is the magnus carlsen
chester final which we have been treated
to absolutely incredible chess and while
on the board yesterday it was all about
the berlin debates and all about
uh
what's going on in the berlin and you
know what we all know that the berlin is
an acquired taste
but to save us from all of that we do
have anish giri with his lifetime
repertoire series with on chessable.com
take a look as anish attempts at a
french revolution
make it actually kind of first of all
correct
like basically correct also like fun i
mean
i'm making like i basically recreate
like i take this crappy french and make
something great out of it
[Applause]
so definitely check that out uh it's on
chesapeal we've got the end games
covered with the covered for you by
magnus carlsen's uh
the
magnus carlson's touch the end game
series on chessable and we've got
other hot takes have all been happening
on twitter and the conversations that
we've been having with all of you
there's some great insights coming in by
our audience and i i want to give a big
shout out to all of you for engaging
with us throughout the store because
really whatever is happening here and
the entire broadcast that's been put
together by chess 24 this entire tour
that's been put together it is for all
of us to enjoy and be a part of so shout
out to our audience for for doing
exactly that let's take a look at some
of the things that caught our eye
lakshman writing in with this battle is
only getting better by the day with the
speed chess demon hikaru's excellent
opening prep and magnus's extraordinary
skill of squeezing a win out of
seemingly drawing positions in the end
game lashman i couldn't agree more an
absolutely blast of a final we've been
having hikaru did mention yesterday when
we when we spoke to him about how modest
he's been being about his performance so
far that at the end of it magnus carlsen
is the world rapid and blitz champion he
is uh he is the best in the world but i
have to say that hikaru is also right up
there he's been he's been the world
number one in the blitz ranking for a
really long time and despite
surprisingly not becoming the world
champion in the rapid and blitz he's
always had a podium finish in both at
least for the last couple of years in
both uh rapid and blitz world
championship so definitely a dream final
with two of the best players and i think
when you take
this format of a short time control into
an online format i think it suits hikaru
even better because he's just had so
much practice it's something that he's
been doing for so long and we all know
that online chess is an absolutely
different animal from over-the-board
chess and in this one
right now it seems like hikaru's the
shining
the shining one all right let's move on
to the next one
we had um
we had anish and anish saying what a
great match between magnus and hikaru at
the magus carlson tour final i'm just a
bit afraid all these victories may
distract hikaru from his streaming
career big shout out to hikaru nakamura
for his 500k followers on twitch he has
been absolutely
such a great ambassador for the game and
everything that he's been doing and how
it's been how much chess has uh boomed
because of his contribution i think
what's been absolutely crazy is to
actually watch him continue streaming
and playing all these games and
interacting with fans right after
playing a grueling final against the
world champ as of now he's balancing
both really well anish so i think we've
got nothing to worry on that we're just
hoping for a lot of fireworks on the
board to continue let's move on we also
had yan looks like we now have a
statistical confirmation that you
shouldn't skip your white games
expecting a plethoric match tomorrow so
yan writing in that he's expecting
bloody fights to happen today on the
board and perhaps not as many berlins as
we saw i think there's a big chance of
that because at the end of it magnus
carlsen is playing catch up and he knows
that perhaps the berlin will just not
suffice and this was uh hikaru's
reaction at game two which ended um
which ended in a quick draw
not not been a surprise for us
throughout this entire final we've seen
that happen on day two as well uh magnus
and ricardo they're sharing a laugh at
just how
uh
how the berlin is
berlin is being found to be funny only
in 2020. all right and of course yes i
think we are going to see some exciting
action today perhaps not the berlins
that we've been getting used to edward
writing in with gm hikaru's lead
illustrates the power of letting go of
the outcome and playing freely not to
mention fab openings and end game
technique and hanging tough and tricky
positions edward i completely agree that
you know i think like we were speaking
about this just his defensive uh
technique especially yesterday holding
on to two very difficult positions just
shows that
he is
it's not just one part of the game that
he's excelling in right now he's just
playing the entire entire format he's
got his a game on in every aspect of it
and with that not to mention fab
openings i wonder if that's a little fun
there with all the fabby talk that
hikaru's been doing saying that his
opening choices and approach has been
based a lot on how fabi has been
handling it going for these uh uh long
castling positions and then creating an
attack on the king side it's something
that he's taken inspiration from fabi
and i think this is a great question
actually to to get a great time to get
yasa and peter on board because i see
they've joined us yes peter welcome
thank you tanya hello everyone and
welcome to set four
of this very very thrilling finals it's
always a pleasure to be with you tanya
and uh
peter
uh you are just regaling me i feel like
i'm gaining 50 rating points
uh watching your chess analysis and i
want to get in there and throw the
patties as well thank you peter
yeah thank you yasir hello tanya
yeah the whole
final is so brilliant i mean so much to
to analyze so much to talk about
and i really hope that they will
continue in the same spirit and after
losing yesterday now magnus playing the
white pieces in game one
it's uh i think it's gonna be very
interesting because magnus has to bounce
back and he has to he has to show the
sign because the fact that he did make
it law yesterday with the white pieces
in game two it might have been a
strategic decision but i did not like it
because he just one with the black
pieces against hikaru and he should have
kept the
uh kept pushing and i think by making
that draw maybe he gave hikaru the
confidence and we have been hearing from
hikaru that he feels right from the
beginning that he had such a nice start
that he has all the chances in this
match and and he just wants to enjoy it
and if he enjoys it we have seen what he
is capable of doing to magnus
yes it's been absolutely an incredible
uh fight peter and i think we've been
speaking about this as well that have a
math situation like this where they're
facing each other every day there's this
massive exchange of information every
day what approach to change what
approach to bring in what openings to
play we've seen that over and over again
we've seen hikaru be extremely
forthcoming with the with his math
strategy and his opening strategy coming
in every day and one of the things that
he's pointed out has been his
inspiration of how fabi's been handling
uh openings and how fabi generally plays
but yes peter it almost feels like in
this format and with this time control
hikaru is
doing a fabby better than fabi
feeling can't be better than happy wow
okay
let me ingest that one first of all a
big shout out to napo what are you
trying to do man uh plethoric and over
abundance of blood
nepo ever whenever you want to be a
commentator just join us i got a hot
seat right here um
what can i say if i was
the manager
of hikaru nakamura i would insist
on an event with a formula format just
like this because this is really a
format
that hikaru excels in i don't want to
take anything away from his classical
chess but from the time that that uh
hikaru was just a youngster he
loved blitz chess and it's in his blood
it's in his dna and this format suits
him greatly and boy
the world champion has a real tussle on
his hands uh peter
yeah i mean
what hikaru has been doing so far was
very very impressive
uh it felt to me like yesterday if after
game one when magnus won that game the
very first game with the black pieces if
anyone would have said that hikaru is
going to take that set three
i think nobody would have believed so
all the more impressive he's he's come
back and the game has just started and
magnus played the move c4 again
all right we're back into an english and
tanya you promise to keep us on our toes
right
absolutely yes that's what i'm here for
so no more berlin going on here take the
take take us through the action and a
quick reminder to our viewers that stay
engaged with us on twitter using the
hashtag impactchest
thank you tanya and peter a repeat of
the previous variations no queen c2 and
no knight c3 an indication with the move
bishop b2
that magnus is not afraid of the move e5
e4 and we didn't see it peter
yeah i mean it's uh really interesting
because
they are already playing this position
for the third time and
basically if you don't know anything if
you are just an average chess player
then after having played bc the most
natural thing in the world is to play
bishop b2 right so why why didn't magnus
play it in the very first game
this is a very interesting
question the point being that
in the first game i believe he did not
expect hikaru to play this system with
bishop e3 and
he somehow relied on some memory maybe
that this quincy to look d1 was a very
interesting idea with d4 but he didn't
know the nuances and mixed things up and
got in trouble then yesterday we have
seen in a must win situation he chose
the move knight cc which definitely
surprised hikaru and
hikaru reacted
i would say a little bit dubiously but
okay it was a blitz game
how should you react if you are
surprised and he got he got into
into some trouble
and uh by now definitely
hikaru must have
uh checked knight cc so he knew going
with bishop e6 that yeah nice is not a
problem so it was exactly this moment
that uh magnus had to come up with
something new again and this move bishop
b2 is natural but the big surprise or
the real surprise is that after bishop
b2 f6 960 queen d7 all very logical
white played the little move queen d1 to
c1 indicating a move like look d1 and
going for d4 uh it's a little bit
similar to the idea with queen c2 but we
have seen that with quincy we run into
some bishop f5 stuff so very very
interesting
exactly queen c1 not the first move to
come to my mind i'm sure
a lot of people in our audience and
again a big shout out to our audience
thank you so much each and every one of
you for joining us i think a lot of
people would be going for rook c1 and
94. and we've seen a very quick knight
d4 in reaction to knight
in queen c1 i kind of would have
if i'm in black shoes there i'm kind of
i'm waiting for the move rook d1 peter
uh preparing d2d4 before i'm jumping
with the knight to d4 icarus said
not necessary i want to play knight d4
right away
yeah this is a little bit intriguing it
somehow shows
quite quite some respect to the move
queen c1 yeah because
the big question is what happens if
black just plays the most natural move
long castle which he had been preparing
with his last couple of moves bishop e6
f6 queen d7 boss magnus really afraid i
mean was hikaru really afraid that
magnus might be able to go d4 right away
that that would be
quite surprising i mean if we just take
a look at something like knight takes d4
knight takes d4 e takes d4 the knight
doesn't have a good square so white
probably has to play luke d1 but this
feels little bit
too sophisticated to be true no exactly
i i couldn't agree with you more that
i didn't see the immediate d4 as a
threat i thought rook d1 preparing d4
uh made more sense but then of course
you could always jump to with the knight
to d4 now having said that
more or less
it's a transposition and the difference
is the key difference is white hasn't
had to commit himself to the move rook
f1 d1 a little extra half tempo that
might be meaningful peter or it might
just mean since bishop h3 is on
black's agenda a move we might have to
play anyway
yeah but i believe you don't want to do
that and it feels like
white is the moral winner of this uh
opening battle because
he did he did save this rugby one and
okay we don't know maybe after long
castle d4 works somehow we just don't
have enough time and we also don't have
computer assistance to to find out but
feeling wise it does look like white got
a freehand now and magnus
tries to make very good use of it with
the timely a2a4 this reminds me of some
some cc reverse sicilian where against
the knight on b6 i mean a knight on b3
some e5 a4 is very effective from the
black side now that's what magnus is
trying to do from the right side
absolutely uh
when i just love those positions where
the kings are on opposite flanks
and uh both sides uh can fiercely sleep
attack one another now this move a2 a4 i
mean we've been talking about it
throughout this entire finals peter
intense chess i mean that move throws
down the gauntlet because b3 pawn is on
pre maybe it's a pawn you don't
necessarily want to capture but you have
to consider it
well you know when you suddenly spot the
move a4 from the right side
i don't really believe that you really
consider i mean
bishop takes bc looks suicidal not to be
honest of course it does
it does indeed but
you know i mean
there are those folks like me out there
that do um sometimes say okay show your
show your cards
and uh it's
it's
it's a kind of a tasty pawn after all
that's a big queen side majority peter
how would you see
uh magnus prosecuting the attack
after
such a
a a flagrant violation as
bishop takes b3 you know when we talk
about something like bishop takes bc
my own experiences in some simultaneous
exhibition come to mind when i make an
attacking move and my opponent grabs a
so
supposedly uh poisoned pawn and you know
you are the
the player who gives the symbol so you
feel like you are obliged to teach a
lesson that no no of course you can't
grab this pawn and
but on the other hand you are also
supposed to react immediately yeah it's
a simultaneous it's not nice to start
sitting here for a couple of minutes so
and then you are suddenly stunned that
yes actually why he couldn't take this
phone right yeah
i mean
as somebody who's given his fair share
of simultaneous over the years
i can very unders well understand
exactly what you were talking about
peter
yeah and uh i'm very happy i don't have
to answer this question right here right
now because hikaru played the move d for
d3
okay
uh
i personally i find that move a little
bit strange because
the pawn on d4 to my eyes was at least
blockading the bishop on b2
and you know i'm almost thinking as
white that i might even want to play
to
e3
in order at a time
to open up my bishop and also to try to
gain control a measure of control over
the d4 square so that maybe after e3
a captures a recaptures i could play
bishop d4 and
proudly pose my my bishop on the d4
square so for me the move d
for d3 comes as a bit of a surprise
um take it away peter what's your
take on that specific move
you know this this move
little bit hints for me that maybe after
easily hikaru is
thinking about considering taking on bc
and he tries to make sure that his
bishop will get access to the c2 square
blocking some important uh files on the
on the queen side because
the other point that
yes you would love to activate this
bishop from b2 but there is also the
argument that the move like bishop ac
and exchanging the dark square bishops
is very effective for white because then
all of a sudden the white knight gets a
perfect
control of the c5 span if a knight on c5
lands and you are not able to eliminate
it it might be just deadly because
connected with the long diagonal this is
too much to handle so i think this d for
this is a very concrete idea because uh
strategically it looks strange but maybe
hikaru wants to grab the pawn or he
feels like the knight on e4 might be
little loose even if i just try to play
for exchanging the light squared bishops
and then whenever you get a timely queen
d5 you might be pinning i don't know
exactly if it's bishop hd and then takes
on g2 then queen d5 or somewhere it
might
prove to be important
all right uh
nice points to be sure but can we ask
maybe even a more important and salient
question we just played a4
and uh as ben larson would say if you're
going to go a4 you're going to go a5
let's do it
uh just challenge uh black to prove
the validity of uh d3
basically if i'm not losing on the spot
then i believe that dtx2 should be the
move to to consider
and that's a question are you losing on
the spot or not peter you might be
losing on the spot if i take on b6 yes i
think
i'll recapture with the bishop please
the reason i want to recapture with the
bishop is to prevent
c7
takes b6 of course i'd much rather have
my bishop on g2 no questions about it
but it's just the species
the the specific moment i remember quite
a number of tactical examples where you
almost sacrifice your queen so you could
play a move like b6 takes a7 and then
pawn equals queen on a8 is rather
unstoppable in this case you can't
capture because of a very unusual back
rank checkmate
a7 takes b6 would be uh embarrassing
yes it does okay the feeling is that or
the question is can black i mean black
has to play a6 and via black be mated or
not
oops
[Laughter]
somehow
this
simple move
uh escape me i don't know why um hmm
well you want it so much to make it work
no that was the right i did i did uh
more or less you were mentioning the
simultaneous and i should have
immediately my my beautiful beautiful
answer
you know rook takes a6 or bishop takes
a6 and mate in 9 peter made it
i don't know how the nine moves go i'm
just joking of course i have no idea
uh what is the evaluation it just felt
like a5
might be and again we've been seeing
such an uh
ramping up of the challenges between
these two great players that i almost
expected
did we see a5
the v6 we did it e5 yeah a5 and he
called who played the move knight d5
okay one indication that yes okay this d
takes e2 8x b6 is hanging in the air but
also just just to play very simple after
dtx e2 rookie one also not clear why
this would be more in black's favor than
than the position after knight d5 yeah
because the rook on e file will will be
opened immediately of course
hikaru's choice of playing knight d5 is
kind of natural because he takes this is
definitely not a movie you even consider
with white so magnus also
trying to use the momentum and jumping
immediately with knight c5
uh before we go any further i'd just
like to say that in these english
opening positions
i love white's position it feels like an
accelerated
sicilian
where i'm the first to make threats
against my opponent's king and so for me
again
for hikaru's fans
don't
don't don't feel badly
i'm just saying that
i don't like black's position and as a
if i was preparing hikara of azanikara's
team i'd say
no
magnus is going to feel himself
really really comfortable here this this
looks
really good for white
i i don't see what's attractive for
blackbeard maybe i'm misjudging the
position
no to be honest i don't think that you
are misjudging it it does feel like okay
white has
very nice prospects black's position is
is dangerous
and if already hikaru is taking his time
for playing the move bishop takes c5
which usually you would play a tempo it
already indicates that aha bishop takes
e5 queen c5 tempo
hitting on a7
is uh
is is a problem yeah i mean it's it's a
problem finally bishop takes e5 had been
played because you just cannot depart
from your light square bishop and you
cannot tolerate the knight on t5 but the
big question is what's
what to do next king b8 has to be played
yeah i was about this about to say peter
i'm stunned because knight c5 bishop c5
was absolutely in my position in my
thinking forced if you move your queen
you're right i could play knight takes
e6 but i could also play knight takes d3
and then you're really really unhappy
you're a pawn down and white center is
simply going to win the game sorry
there's nothing to discuss here so
bishop takes c4 bishop takes c5 to to to
my eyes you know
absolute absolute necessity and the fact
that he thought so long goes to show
he's feeling uncomfortable it doesn't
like
where he's landed peter
yeah
i mean the whole point is you know if
magnus is taking his time let just for
for 30 seconds or one minute go back to
the very beginning because i think it's
very important to understand the point
is that hikaru
relies on the fact that he plays this
setup against the english
i mean the reverse dragon
like this
and this is what we have been seeing
between dubov and hikaru debating for
many many games in different magnus
tours
but the big difference is that if you
know that your opponent always relies on
this one very specific line then the
move gc makes perfect sense because here
after this knight f6 bishop g2 d5 takes
takes knight f3
knight c6 short castle move order uh
black
basically if he wants to stick to this
knight b6 setup he has to play knight b6
here because if black starts with bishop
e7 then white is not gonna play knight
cc but white gonna play the move d4 and
after e4 knight e5 it leads to a
completely different type of play and
it's not part of hikaru's repertoire so
in this regard he's kind of forced to
play the move knight b6 here and thanks
to this move or the magnus has this
possibility to play the b2bc idea i'm
pretty sure that this was the idea why
magnus played in the very first game
against uh hikaru this but then
hikaru surprised
magnus with this bishop e6 it's not
supposed to be the main reaction usually
black players were playing for short
castles but then white was getting some
initiative so we were praising very much
hikaru's choice at the beginning because
bishop e6 was like a surprise
concept but i'm not sure if it's
objectively good enough and it's a very
nice territory for team magnus to target
exactly and team magnus played queen c2
in the inaugural game and then knight c3
and finally a new
a new impulse with bishop b2 peter
yeah and uh this this led to this
position now magnus taking his time of
course he has big choice i mean the
question is
right now what to do with this dc pawn i
mean
don't understand me wrongly i'm not
considering e takes dc the question is
that will you play easy will you play e4
because uh the question about temp is
the movie for you don't really want to
make because it closes the long diagonal
and okay the black knight has to go back
to e7 one of the problems is that if
white would be able to play bishop d for
hitting a7 would be nice but not the d4
square is under control if you play the
move easily then black maybe has time to
exchange the light spell bishops with
bishop hd so that's the argument why
magnus is not playing east yet and the
big question bishop d4 which was the
third option and the most uh promising
one was finally played by magnus
certainly bishop d4 is the most
aggressive
uh that we were coming to later and it's
almost like peter i want to boldly state
the obvious uh when it comes to uh what
move can we expect
look for the most aggressive move
it seems like both players are
are bringing out their inner wolf
because they are really going for it
bishop d4 i like what you were pointing
out by the way just if you don't mind e2
e3
yeah e2 e3 bishop h3
right
right bishop h3 queen h3
uh
right bishop d4
b6
and i just have the feeling that right
here uh
you know i've
i've got this great bishop on d4 your
queen 9 h3 is fine but it needs like
three or four moves before it's ever
really menacing anything and i might
play i don't know takes on b6 cb6 queen
b5 i've got ideas of rook a7 ideas of
queen d3 you know me peter i'm just a
pawn grabber uh at heart but this also
looked like a very tempting choice
magnus as as we've been seeing
throughout this whole match
hikaru as well playing the most
aggressive bishop d4 peter
yeah he played bishop d4 i mean easy was
a very solid choice
uh
basically i do believe that black has to
go for this bishop hc he doesn't really
have any other options so i'm right i'm
not entirely sure what what would have
happened here but yeah after the move
bishop d4 hikaru played b6 of course
there was no other choice a takes b6
c takes b6
and queen ace 3 played
and the big question is does white have
a threat and again we are dealing with
this that should black take on e2 or not
and just when i was about to mention
this hikaru did take on e2
e1 and luke c8 played exactly
okay uh
it it looks
i have to say it looks very scary to me
it looks like what white has all of the
trunks and after rook takes e2 in truth
he white hasn't sacrificed anything
peter normally if you're being placed on
the defensive with lots of
lots of uh
ghost-like threats buzzing around your
king you want to have the solace of a a
pawn in your pocket
yes the only thing uh black can rely on
the fact that he damaged white's pawn
structure so these v2 d2 pawns don't
really do any harm to to black on
black's construction the knight on d5 is
very nice
piece i mean it locks the bishop it
covers the b6 square
and
also this bishop knight construction are
covering all the squares and if black
can make sure that with look c8 look c7
he is able to
uh defend a7 pawn
uh nicely then uh
it might not be so easy for white to
find the follow-up
exactly this is the type of position
where we need to play you know like if
our queen was on a6 like for example if
you just allow queen a6 h5 peter this is
where bishop takes b6
knight takes b6 queen takes b6 is an
automatic and very pleasing uh mating
attack the queen however is not on a6
so we can't sacrifice the queen uh those
types of themes
definitely do exist and we have seen
your move
rook c7
peter played by hikaru
strangely enough
the players are more or less equal on
the clock it has been the case
throughout this finals that we've seen
magnus behind
generally on the clock peter
yes that was something of a surprise for
us uh okay hikaru already said in his
interviews that he is doing some kind of
a nepo style he's trying to play as
quickly as possible putting the pressure
on the opponent
not only over the board but also on the
clock
and this has proven to be quite a nice
strategy you know my big question is now
that you mentioned this move queen a6
what happens if you really
simply play this move
okay uh sorry to say i revealed my hand
exactly i mean i know that
but it's not fair you know
you know you know my intention
um i don't know uh
you know in seattle uh a move like rook
c7 to b7 we would call that seizing the
defensive
uh but really the threat of capturing on
b6 is severe
is rook
rook on h to c8 and rook c one check a
potential
uh disruption in the
in the natural flow of things
yeah that's uh that's a very nice touch
and usually such a move like queen a6
has to be punished with a
nice counter blow yeah because yeah just
shows that this position is much more
complex it's not so one-sided
black has a solid construction if he
managed to exchange for example both
rooks then he has nothing really to be
afraid of because he has
very nice solid pieces so i do feel that
by damaging his own pawn structure as
you mentioned this move easily was a
was a positional and sound option for
white
uh with bishop d4 yes bishop d4 is a
very aggressive and very ambitious
approach but
i mean here white has to find really
very energetic continuation because uh i
would say that time is more on black
side yeah also peter if you don't mind
just for one moment apologies uh
everybody i was i was also if you go
back just a few moves uh to this
position where bishop d4 was played
because you mentioned also a third
possibility i found a very intriguing
peter you the the move e2 e4 you
mentioned and you said as you were
playing this movie said you don't really
want to play this move because you know
that bishop on g2 is crying but if you
play the natural move knight e7 and then
you follow it up immediately with e5 it
does provoke the reaction because you
don't want to unleash
the
dark squared bishop by capturing on e5
in other words you're playing it with a
tempo you're going to go e4 e5 ala tempo
and you're keeping
the initiative
going uh your thoughts please
yes but it's also very committed because
after e4 e5 black might be able to play
f5 and if you are not able to punish
black then you have given up the d5
square you have weakened a lot of
squares it's it's not entirely in the
spirit on the other hand of course you
got a very nice bishop on g2 at the
moment and you have moves like look fc1
it's uh
it's a very interesting way of uh
playing but still it's too committed for
for a rapid game i mean it's not an
intuitive choice fair enough fair enough
the game is so
exciting enough that
and there there's so many really uh
nice variations i mean it's like uh we
have uh an abundance of riches so to
speak uh rook a1 to e1 peter
[Music]
a switch i remember i think it was in
the semi-finals with ding laren where
bang bang bang bang bang there was
magnus uh attacking ding lauren's uh
king ferociously and then he played a
move like rook h3 to b3 and
queen came over to the queen side as
well and suddenly this king side attack
became a queen side attack and this move
rook on a1 to e1
doesn't come to me intuitively peter
yeah i'm i'm also not such a huge fan
because
i mean
my big question is and i still don't get
don't understand
the answer i mean i don't know what to
say if black just keeps everything
intact and plays the move bishop f7 that
was that was the move that bothered me
with the move luke a1 that i felt like
if i'm not achieving anything
immediately then where am i going
okay i believe magnus had to have
something in mind uh it will be very
interesting to ask later what it was but
the move bishop hc this feels slightly
loose because uh you are anyway not uh
exchanging these light-squared bishops
and if you are not exchanging the light
square bishops that it then it feels
like you removed a very nice defender
which was uh basically the soul of your
stability
and uh
i have the feeling that maybe white has
something here
yeah again uh well bishop f7 was as you
say the solid uh
grand masterly choice i see bishop h3
maybe you're right maybe it you say it's
loose
but
it's the most aggressive magnus came
after the brilliancy bishop takes b6 oh
oh oh oh my spidey sense is tingling uh
peter this looks like
somebody over
overlook this tanya
yes your spidey senses are on point
again today because bishop h3 was a big
blunder by hikaru he had to fall back
with the bishop either to f7 or f5 the
problem with bishop h3 is that the queen
on d7 becomes uh overburdened because
now and bishop b6 is spot on taking
advantage of that if black grabs the
bishop with the knight you go rook to e7
and now it's just difficult for the
queen to hold everything together as
well as the bishop on h3 and if black
takes ab6 check this out yes
you go rookie seven anyway because 97 is
met by queen eight mate
nice tanya that's that's a visual as the
brits would say
and after rookie seven if you were to
move if knight b instead of ab6 if
you've got knight b6 on the board let's
just quickly show this line that
rook e7 and now the point is that you
have got no good square the queen is
coming on to d6 if you move to f5 you
can just take on c7 as well go queen a7
and it would be game over a big miss by
hikaru because from a difficult opening
position he managed to somehow stabilize
and then bishop h3 and the world champ
bouncing on this opportunity instantly
wow thank you for that tanya i mean uh
we talked about that too peter it's not
just a question of striking but you know
taking advantage of your opportunities
in those semi-finals i i really have to
feel that dangler in most especially
missed some of his opportunities
magnus woke up on the right side of the
bed this morning
yeah
but you know it's it's so funny that
you remember we we also got fooled by
okay one it felt like aha white removes
his look from the a file yes brings it
to e1 okay it was clear for me bishop f7
was the move and i didn't understand how
to follow it up exactly but when uh
van bishop h3 maybe hikaru felt like
okay this is gonna be a more positional
game and that the rook moved from a1 and
that's why he he he blundered this
bishop takes b6 tactic simply loot by
the fact that ah okay and i have a
little bit of breathing time and that's
how you get punished for that
well i must say uh it optically
i was fooled as well uh i fell for
the bait i thought that bishop h3 was
the ultra aggressive move bishop f7 i
play in a bullet game without even
thinking about it just staying solid but
this bishop b6 really was a lightning
strike you know out of a clear blue sky
that's that's
you know
that's a great
uh tactical shot
yeah and the big question is does black
at all have a move yeah and we see
nicaragua
did capture navi the knight
on b6 and p7 followed queen takes d2
queen takes d2 on the board bishop takes
h3 on the board
and uh
well
uh rook d8 and yesterday it was one of
those
unbelievable game bold
you know tenacious
defenses by hikaru that won him the day
here he's upon down his king
under
oh you're right
whoa because he took the d2 pawn it was
a little pawn but it was there okay not
upon down just as king is under a
vicious assault
of course uh you know it must be a
winning advantage but then again you
know uh hikaru we we've seen it uh
tenacious defender rook d8
what's the clear cut
when peter
yeah that's the big question if there is
any clear-cut way or is it just a
clearly better position for white right
this is uh this is a big question and uh
magnus has three minutes so he doesn't
have another maybe necessary six seven
eight minutes that he can understand if
he has a win he has to rely on his
intuition
and if his intuition
tells him that you know i should just be
happy with the position then he might
just continue playing normally or maybe
he feels that okay no way black can
survive this movement move let me try to
find the killer punch but it might cost
him
very important minutes
exactly that's the other thing
the clock has now become more and more
of a consideration peter i just
uh you know
i would like to take back
magnus's move if you don't mind i'd like
to play in this exact moment rook on e1
back to a1
okay bishop h3 rook d8 bishop h3 sorry
yeah rook d8 the game position right and
now the the rook on e1 is misplaced i
want to go back to a1
and i want to target the pawn on a7 and
thanks to my bishop on h3
both knight c8 and rook d7 aren't
uh defenses that black can employ
uh what's your take on this kind of
perplexing move
yeah okay one was also my first uh
choice because good oh good because
first of all i mean surprisingly there
isn't any clear other move yeah right
and everywhere exactly as you said that
the rook on e1 is hanging that's the
reason why white never able to take on
c7 because black daddy x with queen
takes e1 intel mezzo check and black
wins the game and magnus instead went
for queen a6 this is this is somewhat of
a surprise
uh definitely for for for me on the
other hand it's very nice to get our
queen
cozying up to the c8 and the b7 squared
i just didn't see a very good reaction
to rook a1
queen a6
it's
it's it's not fun for ikaru to defend
such a very difficult position where
essentially when i'm defending peter
i'm looking
at my position and i'm saying where do i
have to draw the line where do i have to
say
this is my resource this is this is what
i'm playing for i must create a fortress
i must
i must defend my pawn i must protect my
my square in this position i don't
really feel
that that black has a very clear
idea of his best defense i mean
uh his structure you know what i'm
saying the king is so exposed there's no
place that you say this is this is how i
defend this position it's a very
difficult
position to defend
i perfectly understand what you mean and
this is one of those things when there
are no direct immediate
threats then it's the most difficult to
to defend because actually you don't
know exactly where the very big danger
coming from you just feel that yeah it's
coming it's all over the place and
hikaru finally just exchanged everything
in order to get this look to the sevens
so luke takes e7 look take c7 queen d1
check everything is based on this very
important intermediate move bishop f1
and now finally black is able to play
the move loop d7 covering the seventh
rank so lookie check will be played and
luke d8 played as well
by hikaru and magnus came all the way
back to eastleigh with the rook
uh i think that that was a very
good uh
play by hikaru track uh trading rooks on
the e file so he could play queen d1 now
the bishop isn't as active obviously
playing a defensive role the trade of
rooks and kicking the rook off the
seventh rank um that was a really big
success i don't know where hikar is
going to go for his next big success but
it just feels that maybe the move queen
a6
wasn't the scintillating uh
you know red-hot
move that that that magnus needed he
still
much much better position don't get me
wrong uh uh white
white is doing great uh the trade of
rooks just feels like
black achieved a little something
something peter
yeah definitely i mean at least he
survived the the terrible assault right
big question the big question
what i'm facing i mean how to get out of
this pin yeah because if white solves
the pin issue on the first rank then
and then gets the bishop to g2 it's
going to be fantastic so of course
magnus goes
with h4 because not thanks to his queen
on a6 which protects the bishop on f1 he
actually wants to go king h2 bishop g2
and then it's curtains because once the
bishop gets to the long diagonal there
is no way black gonna be able to defend
against all the all the threats so black
has to make sure that this king h2 will
not be not be played but how so g5
played it's
it has to be played
but another question engaged to gtx h4
bishop g2 ag3 fgc do you have a defense
i would go ahead and put that
variation on the board
to share it with our audience takes
takes as you said with the pawn and
obviously queen b7 is the big mating
idea queen d7 ah
very
very nice peter uh love it uh that's
that's
game over right there
yeah that's game over but uh magnus
played the move h takes g5 so he doesn't
want to weaken his structure at all
eight g5 fg five rookie seven rugby
seven rookie five played
i mean this looks like a technical
decision i'm
i felt like maybe there was there was
more with king h2
uh i
i tend to agree and somewhere michael
tall was frowning because uh i'm sure he
also felt that there was more in the
position than just you know eeking out a
technical victory by trying to win a
pawn but
uh
ikaro says no no my friend uh uh i know
you're all about technique i'm not gonna
lose the pawn uh rook d5 peter
yeah look d5 and okay as long as you are
pinned
it's it's not so easy for white to
to
to improve the position and magnus plays
the move rookie check rook d8 and queen
b5 ah okay that's the
that's the technical solution
uh i think magnus just uh has seen that
he's gonna win upon and he believes that
if he wins the pawn then thanks to this
bishop he will and uh loose king on b8
for black
there shouldn't be enough resources for
black to hold this position on the other
hand yesterday already hikaru held
uh one position which looked very very
bad with with pon dan so
magnus cannot be sure
exactly i just uh
i i again for those who
who didn't witness the set yesterday in
particular go back
check your archives
see that final tie break game the the
blitz game uh because
we experienced what we might call a
chess miracle as hikaru you know defying
all the odds uh grimly hung on and drew
a very difficult game king c8 peter
yeah king c8 it's it's perfect defense i
mean black has to support the look on d8
and the king on c8 looks of course
terrible but
again once again thanks to this pin
white is not able to to deliver the
final blow
and if there is no final blow then
then okay black is still still alive
he's still kicking absolutely um
all right
i mean
my pawn grubber instincts are here
they're they're they're
electrified i'm i'm
trying to see it um unfortunately this
pin i
i can rearrange my rook i could play
rook e7 and provoke the move rook d7 and
then maybe a check on h8 but i don't see
how i'm picking up the oh wait a minute
why why not rookie 7 rook d7 queen takes
g5
yeah that's that was what i was
expecting when you were telling about
grabbing your pawn
my concern was that okay how easy is to
to win such position because
after all the material is going down and
okay but we have development in the game
please
please let's jump in there yeah
okay g6 was played
http check king b7 wow and what is
happening
so rook c7 check looks like the most
natural force the king onto a light
square very important
queen
takes
yes she
do i how badly
probably i need to capture this pawn
just to keep my own king very safe and
secure
queen c7 check
and then queen takes wow
why did magnus feel his rook on c6 is
better than being on
c7 i'm not sure peter
yeah this is a big mystery for me as
well
uh on the other hand ah maybe
but no twin d6 was anyway not possible
maybe he felt like okay he wants to keep
control of uh some of these squares but
no but you're right maybe queen d6 was
but then bishop g2 check was very strong
yeah
ah the then bishop of course then bishop
gt says no then i'm at a uh then i'm
having difficulties explaining uh no but
hiccup
last move knight d5 explains it all that
with luke on c7 you would have run into
a tempo with knight d5
here you're absolutely right again i'm
mesmerized by the fact that this bishop
on f1 it is in a pin and i desperately
wanted to put it on
the the best square
uh in the in the world g2 not possible
uh queen takes g5 uh peter on the board
uh that finally is a pawn
yeah it's a pawn but knight f4 and
hikaru is back back in business i mean
knight f4
tactical strike
with a threat of knight h3 check
everybody that would be a royal fork and
magnus down to 13 seconds
no
yes and again we're witnessing the
extraordinary tenacity
of this five-time american champion
wow
yeah and after knight f4 queen takes f4
the knight had to be taken
rook g8 checking h2 queen takes f1
and this is even very very scary but
queen fc a super move multi-purpose move
you have to defend g2 in
as well as g1 as well as the h1 square
and any rook check you've got check
check
and mate suddenly a queen g1 king h3 and
it's one of those most remarkable of
situations a very very naked white king
but
no effective check for black
yeah but look at this now we see some
repetition of moves king b8 queen f4
check because after queen fc hikaru
played the khan king ba just moving his
king away from this uh discover check
queen f for check king 8 queen fc
king b8 and now finally luke h6 so
magnus
still tries to win the possession but
having only 30 seconds on the clock okay
hikaru also to be fair doesn't have that
much of time with one minute but with
such a naked king and without any direct
set against the black king i feel like
black is escaping here
absolutely what about queen g wan
check check check check okay you can you
drop he did he drove the king
all the way up to h4
fearless fearless what can you say uh
to move like that queen c1 peter i mean
i would be i would be scared as what
i mean i think i would be scared with
both colors because
because i mean also just one little move
from white like luke h7 and how you're
gonna defend against some son made there
hikaru did play queen g1 queen f4
checked blitzed out
king e8 everything is happening very
very fast so magnus is bringing his
queen closer but does he have more than
perpetual check he's looking
is he's out of
out of game
the the these ladder checks with the
queen are all very impressive and i like
what you said uh to quote anatoly karpov
then what then what peter i mean i think
perpetual check
is almost required there's a lot of
checkmating threats to white's king as
well
yeah absolutely i mean it seems like uh
yeah now we see that the players have
gathered a lot of time i mean they have
now more than two minutes both thanks to
the 10 seconds increment but the law
agreed because there is no way to
continue i think a very very big
disappointment for magnus and the very
very big save by hikaru once again
indeed tanya the tenacious
hikaru nakamura he saves his skin uh
where did magnus
go wrong tanya
i don't think we've seen this narrative
before yes where whether it's been
technical positions and slightly better
positions and this complete mess for
black kind of positions where white is
dominating a player being able to
survive all that uh magnus is throwing
at him and that's what ricardo did with
incredible defense but yes you were
absolutely right the big moment was
after h4 and the point it was i think
the whole game was very well played by
magnus uh uh he
he really created some immense threats
pounced on the opportunity of bishop b6
if we just back up to that moment where
white went rookie one before we come
here because that's when actually things
started to go wrong and peter you were
completely right that this sudden shift
to take the rook to e1 is was actually
hikaru's chance for his for to to
consolidate his position with a move
like bishop f5 or bishop f7 but bishop
h3 was a huge blunder by the american
grand master and of course magnus
doesn't miss these chances immediately
found bishop b6 and it was a complete
magnus position after this there was it
hikaru was just hanging on move by move
and if you just play on i think it was
the whole idea is of course you want to
get this bishop on this long diagonal
that one that's that's the only thing
that's required to win the game h4 was
the correct way to do that white is
aiming at king h2 bishop g2 the only
move to create any counter play was g5
hikaru blitz that out and now king h2 as
you and yaz pointed out
is what had to be done because gh4 might
look scary but it's really not you of
course don't take back on h4 because
then you're exposing your king to
certain checks on d6 and along this
diagonal but simply bishop to g2 and the
point is that after you take on g3 it's
just there's nothing more than that you
grab back with the pawn and like you
pointed out this line queen d7
rook d3 is actually just game over the
computer gives knight d5 is the best
move here but of course that's all uh um
tough child's play this would have been
just the end of it but starting from
this point yes
move by move i
magnus just kept giving up a little more
of the edge a little more of his
position and hikaru just holding by the
thread kept taking all of that in and
eventually
it was around this point when rookie ate
check rook d8 happened and the queen
even here it's slightly better and you
were totally right that white had to go
rookie seven instead of rookie six if
you just move on a little bit i love how
hikaru created counter chances with
every shot he got on the king side every
move that he had he went h5 g5 h4 so
whenever he found the time he managed to
do that and this position white's king
also has got problems and in fact
already it was uh black was doing well
knight d5 was a slight inaccuracy by
black but still it was uh it was already
a big mess magnus had lost most of his
advantage and because white's king is
equally exposed and the bishop on f1 is
pinned the key point was that this
bishop never got back to the h1 a8
diagonal after winning the bishop on h3
and if you just move on till the very
end i think it was uh extremely well
played just in seconds both sides having
threats of checkmate on each other and
maintaining this dynamic threat and
counter threat to make sure that neither
got checkmated and or and the perpetual
had to be played out a big save
by hikaru uh i think i think what was
what was interesting to see was how
magnus handled the opening we've seen
him get a better position in these lines
and i think we're probably going to be
seeing a repeat of that but before that
of course magnus will be playing with
the black pieces hikaru takes on white
uh going to be interesting to see that
when hikaru goes e4 which is what i am
expecting on the board for game two will
we see a repeat of the berlin or is
magnus going to take it head on with
something like the night off
wow thank you for that tanya just a
fantastic game peter i mean magnus will
be kicking himself and
uh he carus all snickers as he
does something
that's incredibly hard he saves a lost
position peter
yeah i think not not to go crazy for
magnus is the main task because i mean
that's exactly what he needed to to win
a game in style and he had all the
chances
everything was under control his time
management was also quite uh quite good
but
i mean the defense
hikaru pulled off was was just
incredible i mean that's why it felt to
me like yeah goku engaged to bishop g2
you have to mate this guy because if you
are just pull up it's not gonna be
enough because somehow hikaru and tanya
mentioned that according to computer
knight d5 might have been a slight
inaccuracy but i believe in a practical
game with 30 seconds on the clock that's
exactly what had to be played and this
knight d5 knight f4 was a brilliancy i
mean bleeds down by hikaru instantly i
mean that let me just get back to that
position because this truly impressed me
i mean knight d5 first of all humanly it
was
it's a new factor this knight on b6 was
guarding the king of black and it was
not moving from for basically the whole
game and then all of a sudden when you
are done to 30 seconds you feel like
okay i understand maybe i didn't play
perfectly from the right side but still
i have a very nice position and you just
need a little bit of time to count
things down and then hikaru comes with
knight d5 queen hg5 knight f4 and then
you say wow
shock and magnus had nothing else than
to
to to let this perpetual check scenario
happen a truly fantastic save by hikaru
thank you peter and tanya unfortunately
we have some commercial announcements i
believe
of course uh we've got so much chess
going on and so much action going on yes
uh 24 7 even after these games are done
i'm sure a lot of us are super inspired
to improve our own play and for all of
that we've got it all covered on
chessable.com we've got amazing series
by the world champion himself uh magnus
carlsen has released his endgame course
and of course the big drop by anish
kerry on the french take a look at this
[Music]
no but nobody likes the french i also
didn't like the french but
like the course
makes it great because like it's
happening but with
i've done so much work
to make it actually kind of first of all
correct
like
basically correct also like fun i mean
i'm making like i basically recreate
like i take this crappy french and make
something great out of it
[Applause]
our partner for the tour final is kiva
the non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help under-served
communities kiva does incredible work
providing micro loans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covit 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world chess24 wants to help make
that happen during the tours final we
will be donating 50 of all proceeds from
new premium memberships to kiva go
premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools in cities and
countries of your choice in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
together
[Music]
support chess and support the community
impact chess has been the theme for this
magnus carlson chester benefiting kiva
final and a big shout out to all of you
for contributing to this uh to this
immense cause uh which gives us all an
opportunity through the game that has
given us so much during a very difficult
time during the pandemic through the
game to give back to the community and
we've had we've had grand masters coming
in from across the world supporting this
cause we've had peter lecko there's been
vassella vancouver
hari krishna
magnus carlson announcing a certain a 10
of his prize money will be will be in
support of keema and some more good news
as uh grand master yasser sarwan also
joins the cause with a very generous
1000 euro to the kiva impact chess
campaign so be a part of it join these
grand masters and of course all of you
who've been going premium during this
time a big shout out to you all of
course i it's a great opportunity to
invest in your own chess education but
also leave an impact on the community by
doing that there's a 30 off on premium
membership and 50 of all premium
memberships will be
will be donated to kiwa's uh cause
yasa thank you so much for your
contribution and uh how do you how do
you plan to use these premium
memberships that you are giving out for
kiva
well thank you tanya and uh yvette my
wife and i are delighted to join the
masters
and to uh share the abundance and to
thank everybody uh for being a part of
the campaign
uh bringing awareness to kiva and
benefiting uh their program uh for
ourselves our favorite charity is the st
louis chess club and scholastic center
an educational trust in st louis
missouri and what the st louis chess
club scholastic center does is it it
hires coaches and sends them out into
the local schools and it positively
impacts the lives of
2500 young men and women in the st louis
area and we're very very proud to
support the st louis chess club and
scholastic center so we're going to give
the memberships the premium memberships
to the coaches
of that program so that they can give
them to the schools
and the kids that they feel are the most
deserving and will make the biggest
impact so yvette and i are very very
proud to join with the other
masters all over the world tanya
that's really incredible to hear yes
because i have been to saint louis and
i've seen the amazing work that the club
does with the
uh
with just the community in general and i
think uh this is a great reminder to all
of us that how we can actually gift
premium memberships and
make it like a big
snowball effect of uh spreading chess
education so
thank you thank you yes for your
generous donation and we've got games
coming up shortly let's take a look at
the action on twitter
this was hikaru before
the game started right before he says
day four are you not entertained let's
see if he can play that if a true
gladiator is what hikaru nakamura has
been and he survived the lions then in
that last game as we saw it was
incredibly what an insane game that was
uh magnus carlsen throwing all his
attack all his pieces to words uh
towards the black king but of course it
was that one light squared bishop that
was just not able to come in the game
and i think it was very instructive from
that point of view as well he asked that
you know you how to
how you've got this agenda of getting
that one piece that you need to kill the
king and how you can go about it and
that golden opportunity to do exactly
that with king h2 which is what gave
hikaru a chance to bounce back in the
game are you not entertained is the big
question
i certainly am
tanya i think our audience is well i
think we're all super thrilled in fact
peter we got two minutes to go well
tanya back to you maybe we have more uh
twitter
tweets that you'd like to share sorry
yes to this fair never sleeps and the
action always continues there we heard
from bizarre dip joy saying can't wait
the match to start and see magnus
retaliate hopefully you will see him
dominate today and come back strong you
know i i feel like it's a bit telling
the kind of positions that magnus has
failed to convert in this
match so far in we saw that happen
yesterday and even today i think again
we've been stressing on this we've been
talking about this and hikaru himself
also spoke about it that this is the
very end of a very exhausting tour for
magnus he's been playing absolutely
non-stop and i do feel this mental
fatigue this exhaustion is really
showing on the world champion and you
mix that up with the very inform in
shape strong prep
good on the clock hikaru nakamura and it
can spell disaster for the world number
one sudarshan writing in with i miss
all right sudarshan writing in with
we'll probably get back to that is
magnus carlsen finally suffering from a
case of chess overkill this is exactly
the point that we were trying to make
easy i think he's definitely feeling it
but we know the world champ he's up
against the wall stamina comes into play
he has it in him he's shown it time and
time again
why he is truly the best in the world
and i think it's too early to write him
off let's move on quickly because the
games are about to kick off ritesh
writing in whether karu wins today then
it will give a big hope and strength to
all the top players yes we always say
that when magnus carlsen is playing a
tournament is that a race for second
place or what well this one is giving us
all some hope right there and let's just
speak about what are we going to see
we've got kick off so yes peter uh
we don't have liftoff yet but we do have
magnus carlsen who's seated waiting for
hikaru nakamura to come and take his
place magnus carlson with the black
pieces hikaru with white uh i think my
prediction here yes is that we perhaps
will see a berlin and not a night off i
think hikaru is going to magnus is going
to try to level this and then go again
with the white pieces your prediction
tanya i think you're right i think
that's a pretty safe prediction uh peter
both players have been happy with the
berlin so far what's your take
well my take is that you remember
yesterday at some point we were talking
about how nicely black is dominating the
match and ever since we mentioned that
things are turning right exactly
commentators curse peter welcome to the
welcome to the booth
yeah but i think it also shows the the
fantastic format yeah that all these
shifts i mean if there would only be one
set each for each match then we would
not be seeing all these intrigues and
all these shifts from white dominate i
mean black dominating then why taking
over and uh in his last two games uh
magnus really put hikar on the verge of
losing
and uh hikaru had won his last two white
games himself against magnus so a lot of
pressure on the black side therefore i
fully agree with tanya one e4 should be
played because it's so logical uh sorry
to interrupt you peter i'm just looking
at the players as they're sitting down
you can see that
hikaru just kind of said you know like
what's going on how come the game hasn't
started you can see a little frustration
the players are definitely primed and
ready and it's like almost like the
starters pistol
for some reason is not going off uh
both players are really chomping at the
bit they want to go peter
yeah i mean definitely it's it's clear
that if you are ready then you don't
understand what's happening but okay
this uh this has been part of the tour i
mean this technical issues whatever i
mean maybe the arbiters are still saying
okay calm down i know that it's gonna be
a big game let's let's take a last
breath before before all this starts and
i'm pretty sure that the game is about
to kick off okay
i think there are certain connection
issues that are being sorted by the
players and i think we're all glad that
they do that before the game rather than
in the middle of it and
we will have liftoff really soon
thank you for that update tanya by all
means do keep us
on our toes and let us know what's going
on as uh they're playing remotely want
to make sure the arbiter's double
checking all the connections are working
you don't want any kind of a forfeit
with the stakes
this high uh really uh
important to do all that uh by the way
peter i just wanted to say that
oftentimes in these matches with this
particular type of format don't ask me
why but sometimes we get lopsided
results like we just can't explain it
but i just i just can't
shake the feeling that we're really
really fortunate that both players are
in great fighting form
yeah absolutely i mean it's after all
the final and uh
we already i heard tanya i also spoke
about this yuyasa mentioned as well that
yeah magnus had had a very very tough
schedule i mean he was coming playing
one tour after another
and playing the finals and winning the
previous legends final against nya
ponyachi probably took a lot from him
but we know how big fighter magnus is
and he's not agreeing he doesn't agree
to something like i'm not in shape i i
want to turn that tiger tied around and
i'm pretty sure that he
he in his last two games with white ever
since he
uh felt like hikaru is taking back again
the match i mean we have seen some
incredible magnus and it was just like
an incredible sensation how hikaru
managed to to save the positions but
magnus is now on fire
[Music]
an incredible magnus up against an
incredible hikaru is exactly how we like
our final uh peter and you know it's
very uh fascinating for me especially to
see what's going on uh on twitter
because there's so much support and so
many wishes coming in for both these
players and thanking them for this crazy
final that we are witnessing the two
have of course shown a lot of respect
for each other whenever they've spoken
about the final but the one thing that
i've noticed yes is that
uh there's a very big bipolar situation
going not a bipolar a polarized
situation going on between the fans if
you're a hikaru fan
very rarely will you also be a magnus
fan if you're a magnus fan very rarely
will you also be a hikaru fan
but i think i'm not sure why that's the
case because uh clearly both these
players have a lot of respect and regard
for each other
i think whether you're team magnus or
team hikaru we can all agree that we're
all on team chess and
this final is a hot final
absolutely tanya couldn't agree with you
more
chess is a very very very big winner
thank you everyone for joining us
peter we are in uh game two
of the fourth set take it away for us
please
yeah and we we have seen the
berlin reappear but with a new twist
after the move fourth d3 magnus plays
the move d6 which he has been employing
quite
i mean quite rarely but uh it's in his
uh it's in the arsenal of magnus's
repertoire one of his victories against
halide zafiduzza from vikanze comes to
mind but there magnus chose the setup
with bishop e7 short castle later
regrouping the bishop to to g7
now we see this very direct attempt by
g6 one of the reasons why this is rarely
seen that white just as hikaru does with
a timely dc d4 can seize the
the center
and we are seeing something of steinitz
louis lopez
with
maybe
half champion for black on the other
hand if white gets the center he can
claim that okay compared to any berlin
scenario this is a dream scenario
anything compared to the berlin yes a
dream scenario yeah i always thought of
it kind of like you say stein it's i
also
credit smislov very much with a very
early g7 g6 looks like a half tempo by
white has been lost what we mean by that
is he white did play d2d3 and then only
later did he play d2 d3 d4 and
black snuck in the half tempo as you say
white's got some spatial advantage in
the center we might see that uh like
with d5 and and eventually uh c4 kind of
a reverse king's india for the moment um
peter
what is the
theoretical appreciation uh of this
position so far do they just say
dynamically even or is white supposed to
have an edge oops by the way uh d4 takes
e5 is a very major strategic uh decision
yes i mean this is something of a
surprise it's uh
it almost feels like hikaru put safety
first in this game because the move dtx
e5 is uh is not a really ambitious move
i mean he just wants to make sure that
he has a game where he's running zero
risk
and
he maybe doesn't mind yeah and look at
this we are seeing the exchange of
queens
this is this is not the most exciting
thing and it also shows
what a great choice by by magnus yeah i
mean he was under pressure and uh in his
last two games in in the usual
anti-berlin stuff and he felt like it's
the time to change and look at this he
changed and it was he called he said
that you know i have respect for your
change i just survived a very very tough
game
uh
i don't want to to enter into your
territory but this is this is maybe what
magnus needs psychologically to build
more and more confidence feeling that
aha hika who has respect
with the white pieces and i'm pushing
already with white and i have no
problems with black
maybe magnus
can benefit from this
a result that maybe benefits both
players nicely put by the way after
knight d2 c6 g3 we would have seen
something a little bit unusual as we
absolutely even
pieces material yeah and king e6 yeah
something like this um
okay
for sure when i i believe that was the
case for sure that when
uh hikaru played the move uh d3 in the
opening he wanted to repeat the lines
that they played yesterday after bishop
c5 bishop c6 i'm sure his his opening
prep was you know tuned to a
home to a fine sharp spear
magnus perhaps sensing that
uh deviated with d6 and i got to tell
you i think that that was a very
very clever uh decision by team magnus
yes it was and you know it's very funny
but then you mentioned this on the was
it the first day the very first the
second day i already don't remember
because i even don't know which day we
and we are here in this match it's just
every day is so fantastic
the point is that when we first talked
about this you mentioned the move bishop
takes c6 i did in this moment and you
know
sorry i don't want to troll you at all i
want to to tell you you know that
immediately afterwards when in the blitz
game uh hikaru shocked me and i think
shocked the whole world by taking bishop
takes c6 here i actually
understood why he did that because i
felt like he could do for this blitz
game he simply did not want magnus to
let the option of playing d6
and he wanted to make sure that he gets
the structure and you remember magnus
also telling us okay what's the big deal
if starting with bishop takes e6 or dc
if you anybody rely on playing a
structure
and that that was very interesting and
ever since i'm thinking about this and
now that magnus played the move d6 i
felt like this is the right moment to
come back to this just to highlight that
this fourth move bishop takes c6 does
have does have a purpose
wow well you said uh i embarrassed
myself of course with the early bishop
take c6 i had meant
to play the the game variations that
appeared in uh day three
and
then we both fell into a fit of laughter
peter when we saw this bishop take c6
and that's why once again we have to be
double double sure with our technicians
that the players can't hear our
suggestions right peter because you know
getting the move order wrong in the
opening and bishop takes c6 was played
now having said that we haven't been
paying too much attention because
frankly speaking the position at the
moment is a really really dry
uh even position let's just leave it
like that um
but let's address it nonetheless any
chance for either player in your view
to
unbalance the game
okay i mean uh white is
half a tempo up so it's a very science
symmetrical position so in this sense
here black has to be a little bit
careful to make sure that he is
he is fully equalizing
but i mean yeah king e6 played
the only way for white to try to make
use of this tempo is with some direct
action
like 95 but but i do believe that
especially with the knight already on c5
it doesn't look frightening at all
and the other aspect yeah and hikaru
played the move bc what i wanted to
indicate that when a player like hikaru
takes dtx e5 and goes along the
exchanges
it already signs signals me he knows
exactly that he's never gonna outplay
magnus in such a type of position so
he's not relying on he doesn't have any
hope of of really winning this game he
just wanted to be solid he wanted to
settle down
and
okay he doesn't mind the draw and i'm
pretty sure that the game will quite
quickly fizzle out because
now especially after bc knight b2 it's
almost like an invitation for white to
exchange everything on the d file i mean
duke takes the it followed by luke d1
and kind of offer shake hands or will
magnus suddenly feel like moment i mean
wait a second my open end is going on
the defensive it looks like i'm the
white because i have knight on c5 i have
some chances of saving the initiative
maybe will i try to play with the nerfs
of my opponent and a5 on the board i i
want tanya to confirm this after the
game but is there isn't there uh peter
maybe you know there's like a 30 or 40
move rule you can't offer a draw early
i think there is move 30 30 rules tanja
can you just confirm that please
okay sorry i thought tanya might have
been there so move okay so i mean
i played in the legends tournament and
there i think the duel was moved 30 but
since it's a show event nobody really
wants to offer any draws i mean it's not
not about offering draws it's much more
that sometimes the position is so
drawish that okay finally is there a
rule or no you can always find a
repetition because uh you understand
when it makes sense and then it doesn't
make any sense to continue as a
world-class player exactly well the open
d file is kind of a chopping block
and we have just seen this move rook on
a1d to d1 proposing to take all the
major pieces off the board
and again it looks like they're really
heading
towards a draw i can imagine that both
sides benefit i think he ikaru
recognizes he dodged a bullet in the
previous game maybe just needs to shake
that off and for
for for magnus uh kind of a bit the same
uh dodging uh
frustrated that he couldn't win the
previous game
uh wants to you know take a deeper
breath uh night endings um
well uh
we know that uh magnus carlsen uh
stubbornly loves his end games as he
made clear in his in-game chessable
course the magnus carlson light touch in
the ending
um peter have you had much experience in
night endings
no not that much i think that knight and
gibbs are quite rare somehow i mean the
the typical end game are usually the
rook and games i mean from that you have
tons of and look at this i mean f5 fcf4
magnus is indicating that no no my
friend you have been way too cautious
with white i'm gonna continue this game
i'm gonna try to put pressure on you and
hikaru has to defend a little bit
okay and so for example after king e2
uh let's supposing you're right there
uh peter that magnus carlson maybe wants
to press his opponent a bit a bit how
would he go about uh doing that
well i believe just uh try to to push
the pawns with g5 the point is that of
course this knight on c5 is very
powerful so white will go knight f2
offer an exchange of the knights on d3
because if you go to opponent game then
it doesn't really matter that you are
more active on the king side for that to
capitalize on you need to keep the
pieces i mean you need to keep pieces
alive but there are anyway only just one
pair of knights not much to to play with
but if black wants to do something then
he has to keep that knight and to expand
so you might see for example to continue
your variation h5 knight d3 97 peter
yeah the big question was where do i
want to to have my knight and yeah
magnus played the movie h5 i'm expecting
knight dc to be
blitzed out yeah knight dc on the board
another big question where does magnus
maneuver his night
right so in my mind uh like yourself
black
to press
i don't know exactly how else to put it
but to press
is going to need to play g4 so if you
imagine after knight d7
and
black needs to play somehow
g5 g4 maybe put his knight on g5
and
you know hope against hope that a move
like h5 h4 is some kind of a threat uh
it's going to be very very hard
to
create any kind of advantageous
imbalance though peter
yeah exactly but simply the fact that
this knight on dc is so nicely placed it
it targets the e5 pawn so whenever you
go g5 g4 and try to bring the knight to
g5 i mean then white will have some a
for b for counter play on the queen side
and your king cannot really move towards
the queen side because it has to guard
the e5 pawn and white only has them
after the exchange of the g pawns uh
only one weakness on fc which is very
well nicely covered by the king so i
think all in all it's understandable
that magnus fell like against the knight
on dc i'm not going to have any chances
and he opted for king d6
he doesn't mind changing and now we are
seeing a complete lockdown of possession
exactly and that's an indeed what has
happened a complete
lockdown as they've reached a kind of a
position
where after for example h4 neither king
is going to break into the enemy at camp
and it looks like draw has been agreed
um
yes
or is about to be agreed uh like you say
these uh world-class players are very
very good at at discovering a three type
a three-move repetition
in this case
i think there would have been a lot of
uh choices
tanya the the tension is getting thicker
around these parts
tension continues to grow because as we
know as games progress rounds progress
of course the margin gets uh
lesser and lesser and narrower to make
mistakes so we are
going to be lifting off the third rapid
game for the day this one was
was pretty even from the start a kind of
a typical berlin situation where really
both sides got nothing and
the reason why
berlin is really no fun to watch yes
let's just be honest about that you were
asking about how many moves it is before
players can offer each other can make a
draw offer to each other it's been 30
moves in the past in the tour but in the
finals it is a 40 move rule so before
the 40th moves the players are not
allowed to offer draw to their opponent
but of course they can draw if they find
a repetition or go for a repetition on
the board some of you have been asking
about the format of the event a quick
reminder that this is a best of seven
which means that the first player to win
four sets will be the winner of the
magnus carlson chess store 2020.
we are already in set
we're already in set four with hikaru
nakamura in the lead in in the 2-1 lead
which means magnus carlsen is playing
catch-up in this fourth set
and uh
the result of the two games we are still
even it's 1-1
i think
yes peter you were absolutely right that
this draw was just all about getting
things together getting your nerves back
just calming down from the madness that
we saw in game one i think
magnus of course must have been pretty
upset about not being able to make the
most of the chances he got and those
chances were some pretty big chances it
wasn't it wasn't a slightly better
position he got a great opening uh
advantage black's king was under a lot
of stress and
magnus managed to
create something but in the end not
convert it into a win and hikaru showed
some amazing defensive resources so i
think this game was just all about
calming down before they take on
before they take on to game three and of
course uh the big the big thing for all
of us is to have yas and peter with us
because they just
i i don't think it's possible to
understand or to really
go through these games without having
without having a commentator a chess
expert really break it down for us and
we all have engines we all have
computers with us but at the end of it
you know when you see lines you can't
really understand the plans and ideas
and that human touch in chess is
extremely important and to talk more
about that uh we have with us
we have with us trainers from coaches
coaches is a partner company with chess
24 that offers
human training so
and training with with this with some of
the best players in the world you can
get lessons from them you can get your
coaching from them and uh like we've
seen how important that is to truly
understand chess that's what chess is
about check it out and joining us we've
got
jesse february and kostya kawitsky from
coaches welcome guys
hey tanya thanks
hey kastia all right so we are going to
be talking coaches with you but before
that
what's your take on the action that's
going on
uh well game one was amazing i was just
watching the game of course and i
thought
i thought magnus was going to win for
sure and then hikaru uh played some
amazing defense i don't know i kind of
got the feeling that magnus would have
won on a different day but
yeah hikaru like really held on very
well
right and
jesse what about you do you have uh
are you rooting for someone in this
final
all right tanya really good to see you
um
i guess not i'm just kind of admiring
the play at this point
and tommy jesse have you been also going
through these games and everything
that's happening with your students
yes i have taken a look at a few of the
games i mean some of them are really
topsy-turvy the ones i really uh enjoyed
looking at especially the banter on
twitter is uh when magnus was pretty
much claiming that he was learning uh
from the mistakes of hikaru with the
back ranked mate and the fork with the
rook and and background that was a lot
of fun
definitely i think the uh the twitter
drama and the twitter branded just adds
the excitement to it uh jesse and costa
tell us a little bit about coaches so
when did it launch and especially i
think what i'm really interested to know
is because i think a lot of us in this
online age of chess there are so many
resources online you know computers
evaluation bars these are things we are
looking at
where does coach has come in and why is
it so important to have that human touch
and training
i don't know do you want me to take this
one jesse
no problem
sure um well coach has i was just
launched in in the last few weeks and
the idea is to
provide an online coaching platform that
kind of combines
uh the chess board and the video and the
phone element and all the interaction
kind of like all in one place i guess
the way typical coaching works is you
meet up on skype and then you meet up on
you know chess 24 one of the other sites
and then it takes a lot of like
coordination between the coach and the
student and there's no kind of medium to
organize that so coaches kind of tries
to
uh solve that
right and
jesse what do you think is
are the factors that one needs to
consider before deciding on a coach or a
trainer to go with
i definitely think it's a difficult
decision to make of course
but what i found is usually you want to
find a coach that you can relate to
so female players for instance would
often relate to a female coach
and wouldn't find that connection really
with an open player such as a male of
course
and
yeah i guess it's just
um
everyone is different and it's finding
out you know who you can better connect
with
so it's not just about how strong a
player is but also to be able to have
that equation with your coach where you
can openly explore perhaps even
psychological aspects of the game as
well as uh technical parts of it
exactly you'd find a 2700 maybe being
coached by a 25 2600 so rating
definitely um
means nothing there's a big difference
between being able to to play really
well and being able to coach really well
so being able to explain something it's
it's different
that's really
really insightful and
kostya i think that's we've got a really
big example with that because we know
that chris little john for example has
been a long time second of magnus of
hikaru nakamura and uh i mean we've seen
the kind of prep that they've done in
the past as well as for this event and
and of course chris is himself around a
2150 player so what's your take on
on the difference between being a good
player and a good coach
oh well yeah great question i mean i
think in uh chris's case he
uh is definitely known to be like a
computer expert and i believe he has
known naca for many years so he
understands exactly the kind of
positions that uh hikaru like wants to
play and get out of the opening
so i think it's very important for the
coach to kind of understand like what
the student is looking for and what kind
of positions they're actually going to
excel in because it's obviously not
going to be the same for for everybody
so i think good coaches they're able to
take this kind of like bird's eye view
and then just kind of explain to the
student like
what's going on especially when you're
working with like lower rated players
you get the sense that they're making
the same kinds of mistakes over and over
again and it's often like some kind of
uh problem in their thinking some kind
of bias that you know you can you can
try to uh correct so yeah of course when
it comes to these top guys i mean
obviously they're they're so strong what
could you possibly teach them about
chess you can still give them like a
second perspective as to like what you
feel like is is going on
right and i think that really reflects
even what jesse is saying about uh the
different skills that are there for
being a good player and being a good
coach a good player is not neces a very
strong player is not necessary
necessarily a great coach and jesse in
your experience of online training and
with the students that you have
what do you think is the big roadblock
for at improvement what do you think it
is that keeps players from improving
um a lot of people who play chess i mean
chess is not their first priority they
have their jobs or studying or school
and that kind of thing so of course
they're not going to dedicate 24 7 to
training chess so having a coach
definitely helps
reach that maybe level of discipline to
say okay set aside this number of hours
a week or here's some extra work and
also there's a ton of chess material out
there so it's nice to have that kind of
guidance uh what to start working on
maybe a certain book or a certain
concept and so on because
all that material is pretty intimidating
when you're just kind of going head on
into
what's out there yeah
yeah absolutely because there's so much
right now and because uh clearly in the
time that we're living in we do have
this time that we can use to improve our
own game whether we we want to go pro
with chess or not i think it's something
that's caught so many people's fancy
just simply because it's the sport that
survived uh castia what's your view on
this entire online chess booming because
i know that you're you know you're
you're a very strong player yourself
i've seen you in reykjavik as well and
what is it that got you into online
training
well online training is definitely like
really convenient obviously because you
can work with anyone from from around
the world
um and okay with uh what's been going on
lately it's become uh i mean chess has
actually i think excelled over the last
couple of months
and uh i feel kind of guilty about it
actually because things are really going
well for the chess world an upgrade for
the world uh outside of that
um
so yeah of course i think
the online boom is probably one of the
reasons why like we've had
uh so many prodigies like in the last uh
decade because you can now learn chess
from anywhere in the world
and it doesn't even have to be
expensive you can actually learn almost
everything from watching commentary
getting very very cheap books like doing
all the training
um and you can play for free basically
24 7 which is i think how a lot of these
players ended up getting very very good
right and i i think uh this is going to
be that's going to this entire boom
actually is going to be something that
most probably and i think i'm pretty
sure about it is going to continue even
when when the over when over the board
chest does return
uh costa i also want to ask you that you
know as a trainer now coming into this
final magnus hikaru
magnus was a clear favorite but we're
seeing a very very strong approach by
hikaru now if you had to explain to your
students what's going on in this match
and and this incredible final that we
we're having
how would you how would you put that
into into words how would you how would
you explain to somebody who's just
gotten into chess let's say around a
1000 or a 1200 player
uh well to be honest my my take on uh
the final and i mean the rapper and
blitz portion is that like magnus and
knock are i think so close in strength
that maybe the difference is
uh
some kind of like psychological or form
element
my feeling is that like magnus has not
been in his best form whereas i feel
like nauka has been at least defending
extremely well and playing some some
really good games uh so to me i feel
like the advantage so far has been maybe
psychological maybe magnus just doesn't
feel in his best shape maybe he's burnt
out like i'm just kind of like totally
speculating but to me it feels like more
of a forum thing rather than anything
going on over the the chessboard
yeah i think that's something that we've
also spoken about uh the aspects of it
being a really long tour and how that's
perhaps having an effect on
magnus's energy and just the way he's
been playing but of course uh we've got
two very important games coming up and
jesse tell us
you know we've been talking about this
online boom and this online training do
you think that with the computer engines
because of course that's something that
all of us use having this human touch
and bringing a human coach into the mix
sort of creates a more wholesome
atmosphere for training
i definitely think so often when i'm
telling my students to analyze their
games after they play whether it be
blitz game or rapid game or classical
game it's it's much better to analyze
your game without an engine because
using an engine
you know before just looking at your
mistakes to see maybe you can figure it
out yourself
it makes you a little bit lazy because
now you're looking at stockfish and it's
telling you exactly where you went wrong
and
i mean relying on an engine isn't going
to help us play better
it's always better to look at the game
first on your own and then go back to an
engine to see you know where
you've gone wrong but just to rely on an
engine for improvement i i don't know
but they say that um
human
there's like a big difference between
human analysis and
an engine is it like the element of a
strategy i know that engines are are
very good at detecting tactics
um but what is what is the difference
between that
um but okay
yeah
yeah that's really interesting and let's
get yas into that because yes you know
this is something that we spoken about
as well this uh
post game analysis which used to happen
so much between players before the
concept of going back to your hotel room
and just checking engine lines what's
your take on this
absolutely thank you tanya i'd love to
join the conversation uh elbow bumps
jesse and costa nice to meet you
jesse for the first time online
um
absolutely my
uh
growth in chats
really occurred very very rapidly
simply analyzing with a group of players
from go to a chess club
take out the newspaper play over the
games of the world championship matches
and uh exchange ideas so i'm really with
you 100 jesse on that
uh is uh
you know analyze your game before you go
to the computer and don't think the
computer is all powerful by the way i
have to interrupt myself sorry i would
really like to invite you both to stay
with us but uh the game is underway and
peter take it away for us
yeah first of all hello jesse hello
kostya uh very nice to have you both
here yeah the game started and we see
magnus
changing from switching from c4 to e4
and he plays uh juke or piano okay i
usually call it italian
uh yeah and hikaru goes for his
trademark setup with h6 a5 he had been
using this the last couple of times
i think even in one of their matches in
the lindurasabe we have already seen
this setup between the two players
so very interesting to see
who will come up with the first
new move compared to that game i think
we are still following that that very
specific game it was bishop going back
to b6 knight gc d5 e5 94 something like
that
uh this isn't the king pond opening from
my scholastics
uh days um
peter uh but i want to get jesse and uh
uh kostya in here uh
do your students uh do you teach your
students jesse
to play e4 e5 and do you recommend
this classical defense to this classical
opening
uh yes actually um i play it myself um
and the reason i promote evil over d4
mostly for beginners
is because of the
opening principles so you know
controlling the center develop your
pieces get the king safe and that's the
easiest way to get the king safe you
know with white pieces
and um
i i i'm pretty sure that people will not
uh you know agree with me here but i
think e4 leads to more of a tactical
game and and d4 positional i don't know
what you think about that
is that true
um
[Music]
it depends it depends
sorry to say it depends on how the
opponents respond and
you jumped in here too uh you
recommending e4 e5 to your students
uh yeah i i agree with uh jesse i think
e4
uh is a good way for for most developing
players to play got to learn to like
play with the initiative
and for black i have a few students
playing like e4 e5 and just taking like
the classical approach playing like the
rui lopez and the italian game and i
think playing that as black actually
gives you a lot of
uh like insight into how to play
different positions strategically which
i think is really really good for for
development
great thank you both uh
peter back to the position uh back to
the game i beg your pardon as we have a
a different approach by uh hikaru if i'm
not mistaken
cars has gone a5 a4 a3 and uh
attacking is that a wise decision
i'm not necessarily thinking that this
is an attacking move it's more like
trying to disturb destruct white of uh
getting what he wants strategically and
the big question is now do you tolerate
this pawn on ac just by for example
playing a move like bc or even a move
like b4
or you just say that okay sorry about
this pawn on ac will disturb me big time
maybe let's just get rid of it as
quickly as possible but it it opens some
squares and believe me if somebody like
hikaru and also magnus has blitzed
things out all the way up here
they must have had a3
on the agenda i mean and magnus takes b
takes ac look at the clock situation
both players started this game with 15
minutes and now both have more than 60
minutes on the clock i think clear
indication that they are quite familiar
with what what is happening here
deep preparation to be sure uh back to
our guests uh questions uh to you first
jesse uh talk a little bit more about
the platform and how
you
match up with your students or is there
a listing
of uh
coaches
on co-chess and
just
talk about the platform itself what do
you like best about it and so forth
jesse you first please
it was launched on the 18th of july and
coaches.com
pretty much has a very easy to use uh
interface so you go on to the website
and on the top you'll be able to see the
premium coaches
and some reviews as well on the coaches
and and below maybe some recommended for
children
and and so on but once you click on
maybe the coach you want to read more
about um you'll see maybe a bio of the
coach and and the fee and so on so it's
definitely easy to use and and also the
nice thing about the platform is
what coaches is trying to do just kind
of roping everything in one website is
to communicate with a student also to
have a board there uploading pgns and
games and and homework and that sort of
stuff so i really really enjoy and even
the video the video feature is cool so i
i enjoy the website yeah
easy to use and you uh cast your what
the what what's attractive for you about
the platform and you are you proud to be
on a coach on the platform
yeah absolutely so i'm one of those
premium coaches along with uh jesse
we've also got uh someone you probably
know yasser grandmaster jesse cry
working with us absolutely
uh yeah along with uh gm michaela
leksienko and and i am alex astanae uh
and i think uh w i am
from romania
and so the site is great because it can
match students up with coaches students
can can see reviews and all the coaches
are kind of verified and trusted that's
not always something you can get when
trying to to book someone online so
that's kind of uh important
um and i i like that it really makes the
whole thing like very professional like
it just connects the student with the
coach it sets up the training in kind of
like a very serious and like pragmatic
way
um and uh well the the board it's very
cool you know all the pgns are saved
it's very much like having your your own
online database i think uh coaches know
like it's very important to be able to
like save your material and have the
student review it more than just like
that one session so i think that's
probably one of like
uh the better features that they have
cool uh
another quick question as we return to
peter uh prepare the answer if you will
please uh
i i have done chess camps where there's
lots of kids
or is a
coach ass
set up for uh classroom settings or is
it more
for the individual before you answer the
question peter
three a4
uh i won a pawn
exactly i mean i have a pawn and i have
a nice position that's what
one could guess by just looking at this
position after all the structure d for
e5 pawns give white chance for
initiative on the on the king side i
mean something like queen d3 is a very
nice
idea always in this type of positions
but it will always be answered by bishop
f5 before you can deliver the checkmate
on on h7 and then the big question is do
you really want to
let the light square bishop to be
exchanged and i think the answer to that
is a clear no
because if black manages to exchange the
light squared bishops then there will
not be any real attack and also the pawn
on a4 might turn to be turned out to be
a weakness after some queen d7 hitting
the a4 pawn so white wants to keep the
tension white also indicating that i
might be activating my bishop via a3 and
making use of that my a4 pawn covers
actually the ac square uh the big
question is how we are black create
counter play and here the the big
question that
will you ever play something like f7 f6
which would open up the rook on the f5
but at the same time would weaken
further than the the king side
i'm not sure about that either the
question the other question is can black
somehow target the d4 pawn because after
all if the pawn on d4 would fall then
everything would make perfect sense for
black hikaru did choose the
semi waiting move with queen d7 just to
show like i mean please show me your
idea i'm getting ready for the action
absolutely thank you and to our guests
uh um
if you could jesse uh answer the
question uh regarding um is co-chess set
up for classroom settings or is it
mostly individual based lessons uh jesse
it's individual
lessons so when you start the the lesson
you can directly see your student and
communicate that way i like to open some
some other platforms sometimes maybe to
share my screen and and show some
slideshow or
some features or something like that
especially when working with younger
kids they want to see something colorful
and fun um so you want to keep lessons
you know very interesting at least and
get super excited when they get
something something right yeah
wonderful well i want to thank you both
for joining
uh us today and to wish you great
success
in this new venture of coaches platform
for coaching and teaching and uh when
you come back next we want to hear all
kinds of stories of how you've impacted
the lives of your students so thank you
both
thank you so much for having us
all right and peter queen d7 you called
it a kind of
let me move and you know what i i really
like what you were saying there about
bishop a3 because if you could go bishop
a3 and bishop takes e7 and queen d3
you know
uh things could get a little awkward for
black
yeah and bishop ac on the board yasser
so
yeah to be honest i'm not really
understanding what hikaru has in mind it
has to be kind of preparation but i'm
not even sure because it's not hikaru
has spent after all he's done to 30
minutes he was up to 17 so ever since he
spent something like four minutes and
usually if you play the move a4 a3
giving this pawn then you really would
love to make sure that you blitz out the
concept which will tell your open and
that wow i'm impressed
but by
playing simply bishop g for queen d7
white might get the feeling that aha you
give me the pawn and that's all you got
exactly exactly
um
well i
i i'm a little skeptical i like i i'm a
big fan as you know of space give me
some space give me uh some pawns okay of
course white structure isn't that great
and yes and yes and yes there is a
potential that the pawn on d4 may uh
come under pressure
but i'm looking at a slave king i'm
looking at ideas from white's point of
view maybe including rook b1 rook b5
where you know on a good day
uh
uh i'm hitting d5 i'm i'm kind of
prepping a4a5
i'm just seeing it kind of easier for
white to play and there we have it a
very direct route indeed by magnus as he
eliminates a knight he prepares queen d3
and essentially peter
uh whether you like it or not you're
going to play g7 g6 here
yeah i mean
magnus playing instantly bishop takes e7
it's clear that especially after look f8
black has solved the problem of the pin
if the black knight could just move
somewhere okay it's still not that easy
to move because whenever you go to c6
which would be very nice to put pressure
on d4 pawn would allow queen dc on the
other hand one could argue that now that
black got ready for with luka v8 maybe
he can play the move g6 because he has
the push e5 e6 under control but
still maybe black just goes knight g6
keeping the tension or even knight f5 so
eliminating this knight
is
is a very sensible way and very much
fits into white's plan because you want
to get this queen dc move in and come
with tempo and then
take one i mean one step after another
because okay you cannot really
have too much in mind right now but if
you just see that you can improve your
position that's more than enough
exactly i have a very direct uh question
for you peter
it seems like somehow
i managed to trick you
i take the initiative when i see uh
attacking chances and when i don't see
good attacking chances i ask you for
assistance uh
i'm looking at rook takes e7 i don't oh
queen takes e7 already on the board okay
what i wanted to ask you specifically
was like queen d3 g6 knight h4
and yes you know what i want to do i
just kind of just
i want to sacrifice not my pieces this
is very important i want to emphasize
this don't want to sacrifice my pieces i
want to sacrifice his magnus's pieces
yeah i i perfectly understand you
i'm even not sure that after queen takes
e7 we'll not be seeing the same
construction because okay i mean the
knight on h4 and then even imagine
something like king going to h2 i mean
knight h for king h2 and then f pawn
advancing so black has to make sure that
he hits hits on d4 as quickly as
possible but
i mean can can you can you really hit me
if i go knight h4 well exactly the
intention behind knight h4 was kind of
to to delay or prevent queen b4 because
well
i was about to say knight g6's is about
to land into the position that there is
uh maybe a counter strike on d4 and it
okay i have 97 check to stop
ah that's
that's a nasty and that's that's a nasty
one
uh peter
nice that's quite quite pleasing from
the right side from the white side
that's right
and after all let's not forget you you
have taken the white side so i feel
obliged like after knight h4 i should be
helping you because thank you very much
it wasn't that fair that you know i
started talking talking and then i let
you answer how to deal with knight h4
well in such moments as a commentator
peter i always feel it's very important
to seize the initiative
especially when it's in your favor and
you get to play the attacking side one
thing i think that after a move like
knight h4
black might want to consider rook a6 as
some kind of a crazy defensive reaction
just that i don't know that the rook
could somehow uh keep e5 e6 under
control keep g6 protected uh
it it does feel however
a little bit
well maybe even a lot of bit uh
artificial i don't know
just your take if you will
yeah i mean
okay six if you get it maybe you need to
but i mean knight g6 is such a big set
especially now that you moved you you
removed the hook from a8 which protected
the e8 so that knight take g6 of course
is an even bigger issue because all of a
sudden oops it's it's checked the bishop
is hanging and you can no longer play
queen g7 because the duke on eight is
hanging precisely so in general of
course this look a6 when you mentioned
it i said wow i mean you are also
perfectly in shape i mean it's a very
nice resource on the other hand how to
get it done because if you have to play
the move bishop a5 first yeah one
doesn't feel like you really want to
move this bishop from b6 which was
eyeing the d4 pawn so nicely
but
you know there should be and magnus
finally played knight h4 because i felt
like what are we missing i mean it's
such an obvious move and i'm pretty sure
that magnus even a bullet game would
have played knight h4 automatically and
now it's a rapid
game and we are seeing that magnus
finally often played a very good game
and then at the end time was a factor so
in this sense i have the feeling like if
magnus has a move which he feels that it
should be played he should not hesitate
he should be doing it quite fast not to
not to run the risk of such scenario to
be to be repeating
remember very nice interview
that hikaru made during the u.s
championship he says sometimes you just
have to trust your instincts and play
quickly in this case
i really like what you were saying to
peter that after the move knight h4 if
you can follow it up
with moves like king
h2 followed by an advance of the f-pawn
whether you go f3 f4 or f4fi right away
that advance
of the f-pawn
the more i'm looking at it the more i'm
i'm saying oh that's scrum delicious uh
everything is going
uh in magnus's favor at this exact
moment peter
yeah i i fully agree i mean i just don't
see it i mean what is the i mean what is
the attractiveness of black's position
you are kind of pulling down okay this
pawn doesn't really make so much sense
but still psychological we know we are
pulling up the b file is open so as you
already previously mentioned this plan
of playing rook b1 first of all
eliminating any kind of film befores but
also targeting this bishop on b6 right
black sponsor and hikaru goes for queen
before so does he indicate that he's
ready to go for that end game because
after 97 it was not not game over you
you had the move to you had the movie
i simply thought like before we don't
get here in the game i did not want to
go into all the details because it might
be just not important but
not after queen before is played this
line is of very crucial importance
absolutely yeah because uh you did show
the nice mate the checkmate that did
exist after 97 rookie 7 yes that's the
one but uh king f8 of course
is the most challenging move because now
uh chaos on the board once again
um
whether hikaru is happy about it that's
a different matter but f2 is hanging a1
rook is potentially hanging knight on e7
is hanging
uh
peter break it down for us what the heck
is going on
yeah if i knew that it would be great
you'd be in the finals
yeah definitely
playing right now in the finals it does
look though that white is rocking it
because
always always always uh to our audience
when you looking at these types of
attacks where you think it's chaotic
stop for a moment and just compare the
kings whose king is safer you're about
to show us peter knight takes d5 queen
takes f2 shack
king h2 and i will make a very
compelling argument that it's white's
king
who is much safer than back black's king
as i'm eyeballing queen h7h8 mate rook
f1 rook takes f7 and i'm gonna deliver a
mate
yeah and we are maybe about to see this
line because uh 97 the knight x g6 2497
check king f8 on the board knight xd5 is
played by magnus yes so basically before
playing knight h4 that was the
hesitation of magnolia
he understood that if i can play knight
h4 and have a follow-up everything will
be fine so black is forced to go queen
before and everything comes down to to
how to evolute this position after
knight takes d5
exactly
i by the way
i i should correct myself i do now at
looking at the position i think queen f2
is really egregiously wrong
because it's just going to open up
the f-file and again black's king is
about to get killed i'm not so sure
about the endings however peter what's
your take uh if black avoid what do you
first of all do you think he should play
queen f2
yourself well it's a very tough choice
the the problem is that of course you
would love to take a pawn because this
pawn is is quite important for white
structure on the other hand if you are
taking the pawn and then you will not be
able to exchange the queens then you
most probably gonna get mated
uh the other question is that if you
just take on d3 for example bishop takes
this bishop d4
then
still some fork on c7 is coming there is
also some fork on f6 looming
i'm not sure how comfortable black is
about this and uh let's not forget even
after taking on e5 black still will be
upon done so the end game is maybe not
not a dream scenario and hikaru chose to
go for this queen takes f to check but
wow i cannot believe that this works i
mean king h2 and okay of course only
move but what happens after rook f1
that is the quick key question because
bishop f5 bishop f5 that's the resource
boy i was about to say without i did not
receive that resource i i even saw that
later bishop e2 i mean pardon me it's so
complete but i mean after bishop e2 i
have moved like queen h7
yes and i'm threatening mate and the
queen yeah and if you go bishop f5 i
have the
side check queen a3 yes
but you have the move queen c5 i mean
it's a crazy position sorry to interrupt
but takes this
even after taking on f5 you take on d5
and after bishop bc you have the move
look he takes e5 uh
keeping things under control of course i
don't have to play bishop bc i can play
look f look af one looking promising
i don't know i mean let's go back to
luke 88 let's calm down and let's take
let's let me ask you what you think of
this
you said let's calm down my heart is
ticking really really fast because my
spidey sense is tingling right here
right now i think hikaru
has
given
magnus a
stellar chance of showing his attacking
prowess
and
first of all it's remarkable rook f1
bishop f5 but that looks like the right
starting move
i mean i can't imagine some ridiculous
move like a5
you know that's just kind of like weird
that's that that's alien stuff we're
going to stay away from alien stuff rook
f1 tanya that looks like
good stuff
what's going on tanya
it's very good stuff
for white here to go rook f1 yes and in
fact queen f2 was a big mistake so both
of you were completely right that
opening up this f file no matter how
tempting it is to take the pawn on f2
was a bad bad idea for hikaru the way to
play her was simply to grab the e5 pawn
with rook e5
and now because there's a threat of
queen f2 and rook h5 made blight can
take the bishop on b6 so white white
goes knight b6
and you take
trade off the queens pick up the knight
a slightly better ending for white but
black can still try to create some play
and some resources here but this was the
way to go instead queen f2 king h2 and
now rook d8 rook f1 on the board will be
very difficult for black in fact and
you've got two options here again as
peter pointed at bishop e2 and bishop f5
take a look at what the computer says
for bishop e2 to move queen to d2
and now you've pinned this bishop on e2
but also you're threatening the pawn on
h6
and this is and the queen on f2 of
course hangs and the only move for black
here but it doesn't have to cause is
actually queen to e3
so the mess just
the mess just continues you just simply
trade off the queen
and pick up the bishop with the knight
and this is a good position a very good
endgame for white and instead of this if
you go for bishop f5
white's got a huge a huge advantage in
that last ending we saw if you go bishop
f5 then you're absolutely right peter
you go queen e3 queen a3 check queen c5
queen c1 you don't even need to trade
off because whoa
queen c1 is again so this eight six
spawn in both these lines that we saw on
scene with the move like queen d2 and
queen c1 just eyeing this h6 weakness
which doesn't come very easily for us to
understand you know there's this little
pawn just at the edge of the board and
rook f1 is on the board of course a big
decision for hikaru to go bishop f5 or
bishop e2 the point if you can just
bring back that queen c1 position
yeah and just a second tonya to
interrupt let's take a look at hikaru's
camera i mean hikaru is going crazy i
think because he maybe just realized
that he had missed some some detail and
he's in trouble
i think he he does know that peter you
can we can totally see that with his
expression we've often seen hikaru not
look at the board he does this even in
over-the-board chess where he's
extremely expressive as a player and you
can he's one of those players i think he
reminds us all of a little bit of gary
in that way uh his expressions are very
telltale of what's going on on the board
and what's going on in his mind rook
efron on the board the only two moves
bishop e2 bishop f5 and as we were
discussing with bishop f5 i just quickly
want to go through this line queen c1
king g7 the game still goes on but the
point is that after rook f5 rook d5
hmm
and now qui
and now queen two f4
threatening the pawn on f7 and if you go
if you fall back with the rook to d7 or
r7 because you cannot allow rook f7
queen f6 coming in you you don't have
time to pick up the bishop on c2
this is disaster
so instead if you fall back with rook b7
this opposite color bishop is actually
clearly better for white with a move
like bishop b3 because f7 pawn is very
weak and we know that in opposite color
bishops it's not about how many pawns
you have but the safety of the king and
rook coming to f1 f7 being extremely
weak this is
all white
all round
wow uh thank you very very much for that
tanya i just uh before you do break away
i was thinking okay
man rook f1 uh
rook takes d5 tanya i mean i i i closed
my eyes is it is it
nah that's just
yeah no i can't do it i was going you
can't take on c2 because of f7
unfortunately exactly and this now
bishop e6 is not desirable it looking
very very tough for the american peter
yeah absolutely i mean uh magnus on fire
and again you know it comes to mind but
this is maybe all chess.com i mean chess
24 or uh or chessable uh
fault because ever since you know this
advertisement of magnus attacking vida
sacrificing appeared it looks like
magnus is getting all these positions of
you know just uh attacking for free and
here he did not even sacrifice anything
yet you know and he is pawn up even in
that very last position which tanya
mentioned i mean after capturing
everything you remember here opposite
colored position after duke d7
and white is still pawn up
and attacking you know this is
completely crazy i mean this this whole
sequence and you know it it feels like
there is this mystic that whenever
magnus gets an attack he gets it for
free
it true and also there's that nasty
nasty looking move e5 e6 with you know a
terrible discovered double attack this
looks like uh you know a tactics
uh uh
uh gone wrong so to speak so rook f1 and
as tanya was saying i mean
uh hikara is such an expressive player
over the board he shakes his head
vigorously he definitely feels
well he realizes that
he
in a crucial variation
he's miscalculated something peter and
what is he
what well we've seen his tenacity i mean
he's come back from what we think has
been miraculous saves
uh magnus if he doesn't if he doesn't
win this one i think
i think we got a uh
we could have a suicide watch i mean
like what does he have to do to win i
mean tanya i feel magnus has to win this
game not only to stay in the match and
eat and and
and uh so forth and so on but i mean
just for his own
self
good feelings about himself
oops sorry tanya's not there peter
you're looking at a different variation
rook takes e5 yeah because luke takes e5
had been played by hikaru and i think
likely
it is the only way to play i mean you
have to create contra chances because
you understand that you you're gonna be
mated and i wonder maybe that from
distance
hikaru relied on this that uh he's
escaping thanks to this duke takes e5
right and uh to his horror he had to
realize that he missed something in his
uh calculation i can see it right away
what he missed he probably expected
bishop takes f2 and thanks to the threat
of rook h5 check and mate he was
anticipating that knight f4 would be
forced he could capture the queen but as
you're pointing out uh peter uh
white has this beautiful little
intermezzo move the square a3 remember
when white played move a4 how could
uh
magnus have guessed his queen needed the
a3 square beater
yeah i mean this ac square he already
made very good use of it with bishop ac
and capturing this
knight on e7 right and of course he
couldn't take on f2 he's
taking on d5
but but this is clearly something that
he had to come up with
uh simply by elimination because it
looks very very bad
okay now rook takes d5 on the board
um
[Music]
is there a forced win for magnus again
boldly stating the obvious magnus has
missed
some terrible opportunities in this
match that he really can't believe uh he
hasn't won
uh he's winning now
but
there's tricks peter
yeah tricks all over the place uh
but uh
magda still has i mean he had like five
minutes when
dtxd5 was played and he has already been
calculating this line so i believe he
should be able to figure it out
peter absolutely i have no doubt that
magnus will be able to and he's done it
rook f7 on the board this was the big
blow and magnus carlsen shows that he's
up for the task in this one hikaru has
come out of some hellholes in this match
but i do not believe this game is going
to be it and now the computer shows that
white continues to insist on the
sacrifice with rook f8 the entire point
of giving up this rook for the f7 pawn
is that you want to open the f file for
your other rook to join into the attack
king f8 you give a check and whether you
if you go king e7 here
but we do have moves so let's stick
because queen eight seven comes in and
white is winning here we will come back
to this let's keep up with them with the
position on the board
yeah magnus took on d5 he didn't play
luke f8
he took on d5 luke takes d5 bishop g6 i
mean it looks like a technical even of
course luka f8 was a brilliant uh human
way of winning it this queen takes d5
bishop g6 is maybe exactly what a man
with nerfs needs
yeah i i must say that uh the rook f8
variation tanya you're gonna have to
share that with us at the end of the
game but bishop g6 to my eyes looked
like the more human move because i'm
sitting there going i'm terrified just
terrified peter of the rook h5 landing
with uh checkmate all my friends are
going to be laughing at me so i'm going
to play bishop g6 and make sure i'm not
going to lose a brilliancy that will be
published until the end of time rook e
won after king d8 peter
yes and look one this is very very
important because white has to go with
the initiative
let's just imagine that the black king
somehow miraculously escapes on e7 and
then with this damage pawn structure and
thanks to the very nice construction
from black there are very good drawing
chances and we have already seen uh
hikaru escaping so many times
so magdus definitely wants to make sure
that he will not let this king escape
because that's the biggest problem for
black a part of being material done
right and with this move rookie one i'm
anticipating a move like rook on f7
to g7 so that the e8 square which is
will then be protected by the bishop
will erup allow for the double rook
checkmating pattern and uh
yeah that king unfortunately just as you
said if the if if the king were
magically
uh escorted to the
a7s
square there's fighting chances
not so in this case it looks like to me
the king is rather trapped but having
said that
okay let's imagine i don't know peter uh
what can i i i think i'm gonna have to
no bishop d7 immediately i have to play
c6
because bishop d7 immediately runs into
rook f8
yeah but i mean if c6 then you i lose
that's right
yeah exactly i mean i mean basically i
think the big problem is that black
doesn't have a move
that's uh that's the problem i mean he
is motherly done and you would need a
very good move and finally c7 c6 played
out of desperation because this is
certainly not a move you want to play b7
pawn is falling with the tempo but
simply there was nothing else
i i was about to say was that the move
tricky move bishop h5 peter
uh for black i mean c7 c6 is kind of
about as close to resignation as you can
get bishop h5 might have been a better
fighting chance is there just a or is
there just a clear refutation peter
well i believe there should be a clear
definition because otherwise hikaru
would have played it for sure knowing
knowing hikaru i mean maybe do i have a
fourth win with just look fa check king
d7 bishop f5 check
followed by g4 yes you do
and that
getting out of it no not just this but
there you go because king c6 lands into
bishop e4 right and king d6 lands into
look d8 check
also and um i mean i'm also i can take
on d5 bishop e for bishop takes b7 i
mean everything falls apart maybe i have
even something else
yeah the the something else that i saw
was g3 g4 with the rook on fa trapping
the bishop and i went okay okay
you have to close my eyes well done you
you went yeah that so that was why we
saw c6 but that
has disaster written on it
as well peter
yeah
exactly i mean
this is not the type of position where
there are no miracles you know uh the
way he calls so far survived it
indicated very much this line like
tanya shared with us that black had the
move luke takes e5 instead of queen
takes f2 and
in in this line
white is better and it would be a very
typical scenario of what we have been
seeing in the last couple of games of
magnus being pulled up having the better
possession but then hikaru defending
uh but
after this look f1 i'm pretty sure that
hikaru did not miss luke f1 he just
believed that he has this contrast like
with rookie five and
he he missed luke takes f7 or him is
queen ace lee right i agreed all around
because
uh that ending that tanya showed versus
the middle game after rook f1 and no
comparison and again it had to be a
calculation
mistake by hikaru hikaru calculates very
well
can calculate a loss
as
magnus carlsen takes a one point lead in
this
third set
tanya what a
man what a tense game
very very tense had us on the edge of
our seat throughout and that means
hikaru nakamura is in a must win
win on demand situation going into game
four the final rapid game of today so
that he's able to take the uh take the
set into thai breaks which is going to
be blitz hikaru nakamura will be playing
with the white pieces and will need to
win that game against the world champion
this game was absolutely immense super
impressive play by magnus finding the
right moves at the right time with the
right blows rook f7 was absolutely
brilliant you were totally right peter
that bishop rook fade continues the
brilliancy but queen d5 rook t5 bishop
g6 is just a very human way to go into
an endgame where you don't need to
calculate and you're completely winning
and this is not one of those slightly
better extra pawn but black squad
resources kind of position this is just
game over and that is what we saw so he
karu now has to think about what to do
against this
geico situation that he faced here and
if you are wondering what you need to do
against e4 we've got help at hand
because we do have a lifetime repertoire
cost by aneesh giri
where he shows us and where he tries to
make french great again have a look at
this
[Music]
no but nobody likes the french i also
didn't like the french but
like the course
makes it great because like it's opening
but with
i've done so much work
to make it actually kind of first of all
correct
like
basically correct also like fun i mean
i'm making like i basically recreate
like i take this crappy french and make
something great out of it
[Applause]
our partner for the tour final is kiva
the non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help under-served
communities kiva does incredible work
providing micro loans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covid 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world chess24 wants to help make
that happen during the tours final we
will be donating 50 of all proceeds from
new premium memberships to kiva go
premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools in cities and
countries of your choice in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
together
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
[Applause]
[Music]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracies yeah years later yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up
[Music]
you look at farmers in the rural areas
of tanzania and uganda the way that they
farm is very manual labor intensive and
they can't afford to buy equipment
outright and so we're focused on raising
the level of income by selling
productive use equipment with financing
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
what
no but nobody likes the french i also
didn't like the french but
like the course
makes it great because like it's opening
but with
i've done so much work
to make it actually kind of first of all
correct
like basically correct also like fun i
mean
i'm making like i basically recreate
like i take this crappy french and make
something great out of it
[Applause]
with some very hot takes on the french
and recommends it as a lifetime
repertoire and tells us how we can make
the french great again and all of that
on a great inaugural price as it goes up
with a 40 percent inaugural discount so
definitely check that out if this entire
final has left you wondering what do you
do against e4
and of course uh besides opening there's
so much more that we can do with chess
and improve our game and a big part of
that has been the magnus carlson chess
store giving us this super entertaining
uh broadcast and tournaments featuring
the very best in the world fighting for
the biggest prize fun in an online event
absolute world-class stress over the
board and if you have enjoyed that and
if you want to see more of that happen
you can support the tour you can support
the work that chess 24 does by investing
in your own chess education go premium
at a 30 discount for all premium member
benefits including some intense training
resources on
chess24.com and the best part is that by
doing that you also give back to the
community as 50
of all premium memberships during the
finals will be given to help kiva
borrowers and i do hear that in
september once the tour is over the kiva
finals uh code for the discount will
expire and in fact premium membership
does jump a price so right now is a
great time to consider going premium
support chess support community support
everything that has uh
made us all survive this summer
and uh of course the other thing that
makes us go on has been all of you on
twitter and your interaction with us and
your engagement with us so let's take a
look at the action but before that again
a big shout out to ivet and to yasser
for that generous contribution to the
kiva campaign donating premium
memberships worth 1 000 euro and as yas
pointed out earlier that these will be
given out to coaches in saint louis who
go out and help the community and train
the community and perhaps pass it on to
their students whatever resources
they're able to benefit from from this
subscription so big shout out thank you
for that yes and let's take a look at
what's been going on in the twitter
world
women writing in with well done hikaru
rooting for him how are players able to
play so fast are they using a touch
screen to play mo i i i don't think
they're using a touchscreen i know that
in the past some of the players have
been
using the
oh my god and i'm totally blanking out
on what what it's called the
the red thing
on the laptop someone tell me what it's
called but you know what i'm talking
about the mouse button the the red like
the old ibm
mouse button
what
it's called a track point track point
sorry there you go we know that players
have actually been using that which has
been which is very very difficult to
play with but i i hear that even some of
i think it was even a niche using it but
i'm not really sure on that i think the
players are using a normal mouse i think
touchscreen would just mean so much
mouse slips going on i feel on the
screen could get very tricky with that
magnus is indeed from another planet and
hikaru nakamura is playing catch up in
today's set going into the final game
let's see what happens
we also heard from
sonic
gm
is really showing off his skills against
magnus carlsen and those games are just
a treat for the eyes to see and lots of
lessons to take from the games
absolutely i think there's so much uh so
much
just instructive educational
entertaining chess that we're being
treated to and a big shout out to our
chess experts grandmaster yasser saravan
and grandmaster peter lecko for calling
out the action and breaking all of this
down for us because otherwise it just
goes over our head all right let's move
on
we also got john writing in shout out to
john he's been a big follower and a
supporter of chess 24 and the entire
tour we've heard lots from him thank you
john
an amazing save by our american champion
hikaru and the world champion really
took the fight to naka incredible first
game all around i think i think hikaru's
been surviving by the thread in some of
the games of the past and shown immense
defensive resources but what we saw in
the last game in game three of today's
set there was just no coming back after
that queen f2 disaster i think it's just
the kind of position which basically the
king is so exposed all the pieces are
thrown towards the king and uh it ended
up being an end game with absolutely no
chance to hold on to so hikaru nakamura
must win the next game for us together
to get a blitz tie break for today's
game
simon maybe i'm missing something but it
seems that d4 is a much better way to
play for a win compared to e4 well the
last game might have put that into
question definitely no berlin there
because we saw a geico we saw bishop c4
instead of bishop b5 there and uh yes
it's um it's been interesting like that
the opening choices and how black's been
the one who's been pushing so far in
this entire final with white really
struggling to get something out of it
and i wonder yes if uh
it's also interesting like
for one d4 is there something as solid
as the berlin like we see against 1e4
because i can't really think of anything
well the queen's gambit declined has
been the go-to
uh defense a big shout out to simon
williams thank you so much simon that
you're watching the show uh simon of
course has some marvelous chessable
courses that you really really do need
to
uh check out so queen's gambit declined
has been been used
for generations in world championship
matches um
at one time the lasker
uh
the the the exchange that lasker
emmanuel lasker introduced uh vichyanaj
your countryman was using it also for
his world championship matches and
defeated
vessel and
[Music]
pound so yes uh
i don't i actually like d4 over e4 i
think e4 is too much theory for me uh
only hard workers like peter lako
can possibly find the answers in e4 uh
peter your
your answer to uh
our colleague simon williams
well i mean okay
simply i believe that magnus is not very
much on track because
he has been
imposing really big pressure on hikaru
and he he won this game this third game
with e4 i mean the italian the juke or
piano and to be honest i think the scary
thing is and we have a lift off uh he
can't stick to his one e4
that
and that
i don't know what went wrong with
hikaru's preparation because it felt
like he blitzed out man all his moves
and all of a sudden he started to think
and the position didn't look attractive
at all and we have the repeat of the
berlin variation and dc d6
on the board and the same very same
variation with g6 also
that we saw in game two
uh in that game after d4 bishop d7
bishop g7 wow bishop
what's that
what
is that
holy smokes
has
magnus made a mouse lip that
peter well
he played bishop d7 in game two achieved
a very very comfortable draw
um after d takes e5 et cetera et cetera
but bishop g7 isn't he just inviting a
capture on e5
yeah but something i mean this has to be
i cannot believe uh magnus mouse
sleeping here and
hikaru is not even
calling the shot i mean
why i'm saying not calling the shot that
he played short castle relatively
quickly basically indicating that i'm i
don't buy it i understand that it's not
a mouse slip
so castles castles played now ready
taking the pawn is obviously too late
because black is not pinned anymore so
this is uh
this is some
i think correspondence stuff so after d
for bishop g7 if instead of castles
let's just go back
because nahikadu is taking his time
white takes on e5 then black gonna
definitely take on e4 i believe
okay
and uh okay something like queen d5
looks scary but maybe it looks more
scary than it is because okay i might
just go with my knight to c5
and i'm ready to sacrifice this pawn on
c6 and okay give me just one more tempo
short castle and i will be very very
happy
isn't the common move in such positions
bishop g5
now peter
yeah bishop g5 is the critical move
and uh and that's why it's probably
played in correspondence chelsea
a good time to stop indeed let's get
back to the current situation because in
fact we do have a very
classical
challenge a game where
white once again like many kings indian
oftentimes presses in the center with d4
d5 and black answers with a counter
punch on the
king side peter uh you have much
familiarity yourself with this
opening and by the way it looks
look looky looky uh we've got a very
special guest it would appear having
joined us grandmaster anish
hello guys hello
yes hi anish fresh your french
uh frenchman the frenchman french
chesabol uh
um
course anish nice to have you with us
what is what's your take of this
match thus far this finals just this far
yeah i've been quite busy these last few
days um i played also the olympia i was
rooting for the dutch now i'm rooting
for the french but
overall overall i've been fascinated of
course by the match i mean it's so great
to see when somebody is able to put up a
fight uh against magnus carlsen and
hikaru i mean he carries even leading
that's that's incredible but today is
going to be a difficult uh difficult day
obviously he is trading so i i don't
know if he can pull it off but if
someone can probably see karo so let's
see let's see
okay anish now that you're here i just
got to ask you
talk to us about your course but also
you've got to ask answer a key question
i always ask it because i like to say no
matter how badly i teach i always learn
something myself
first of all what have you learned about
your own chessable
course on the french opening
yeah it's a bit pity of course that the
guys don't play along and instead of uh
you know promoting my french course they
keep playing the berlin that's that's a
big that's a big blow so whatever i'm
going to say now is not very relevant uh
to the game
but uh you know it was a lot of fun you
know when you are studying for yourself
whatever it is you are you know studying
for yourself but when you're studying to
try to explain something to somebody you
start realizing that well wait a second
here i don't really know what i'm saying
you know or i don't really understand it
so when you are explaining something to
someone you grasp the essence much
better yourself you understand things
much better
and that's that's the case with anything
you know when back at school i tried to
explain something to my smaller sister i
understood the subject better too so i
think that's uh i've definitely learned
a lot more about the french and uh i
mean to say i fell in love with the
french would be an exaggeration
but
it is definitely not as bad as peter
thinks you know it's not as bad opening
as we thought it's really okay
that's very very reassuring
especially the especially the vin number
not this knight of six nonsense where
you allow e5 and f4 and all that but the
venova is quite sharp it's a good good
counter play um i mean also um
given the way magnus plays the berlin
i think uh french would have been
would have been appropriate too i mean
now what is what is going on here it's a
very strange position it reminds me a
little bit of
the other berlin where the bishop was on
b6 here it's on g7 so it should be it
should be decent position for blackhead
yeah i have the same feeling yeah
that those lines with dominguez used to
play yes bishop d6
yeah with bishop b6 yeah
now c6 is hanging so how to protect it i
mean queen d7 is a little bit c5 okay c5
is cool dc and then what the idea d5 or
dc what's the point
yeah that's a good question i i believe
maybe d5 yeah it looks
but magnus is in the book he plays so
fast is it prep or something or what
i guess so i mean yeah so far magnus
haven't been so fast so if he's fast now
it should be that he's in book i mean c5
you cannot play i mean magnus he
actually is a pretty traditional player
he likes to take his time at critical
moments he is one of those players who
don't want to skip critical moments no
matter the time control so if he plays
c5 fast i'm pretty sure it's his prep
is it dc d5 and e5 bishop f5 is that the
point maybe or
i don't know i'm just trying to guess
also
knight d7 was 97 was simple instead of
uh super 5 97 maybe just
yeah i mean it looks like black has a
big choice and all of them look quite
quite tempting and the point of c5 is
that now d4 pawn is gone and e5 pawn is
falling yeah so he's he's broken the
center apart
yeah and compared to the lines in the
other one which we indicated with bishop
on b6 after c5 d5 the bishop was trapped
now the bishop is fantastically placed
there fantastic
although how how clear is okay how clear
is this i might want to go h3
okay i can also do this c6 business
this is d5 yeah yeah and if i play the
simple move h3 instead of uh
instead of everything is that the thing
he's considering as well or what takes
takes
um
i could get like if i stabilize i could
get a small plus but i doubt that white
gets to stabilize i imagine there are
all kinds of tactics here
yeah
[Music]
knight f3 let's say
d5
e5 maybe
yeah knight e4 or knight d7
black is definitely okay no
yeah that's that's my guess but also
once you know that somebody blitzes
things out you simply assume that it
should be fun yeah
yeah it's of course uh
quite remarkable to play this d6
variation and then analyze it so deeply
it's a strange approach but a very
remarkable one
yeah you know it's so unpleasant when
you only must win and you don't even
like you are in a must win and instead
your opponent is the one prepared that's
very frustrating i guess
yes exactly i mean that's that's a
nightmare scenario because you feel like
you are not in control and things are
happening not with your agreement i mean
it's just happening because it's
happening
yeah yeah it's true and you are you know
when opponent plays so fast that you are
facing
not just uh magnus carlsen to 8800 but
the magnus carlsen's engine which is the
3800 so it's not so easy
yeah no not looking good for hikaru
today i guess
but let's see
yeah yeah please join in i mean yeah no
i've been listening i've been enjoying
your commentaries very much
and uh for me i'm kind of reeled back
by the move c6 c5 which as you say on
issues just grab them yeah grab them
grab them baby it was it was played all
the tempo because if you had played if
black had played a move like bishop d7
in a must-win situation you're kind of
happy as white because you've got an
imbalance that you can fight and i
remember this very very frightening
computer program ages ago it was called
hydra it had played against mickey adams
and
beat mickey adams uh terrible probably
because i was mickey's coach for that
match uh but really they they were
coaches for these engine matches yeah
yeah and it wasn't good but c65
the more i'm looking at it it really did
it looks like it's solving very very
nicely uh yeah it's prep for sure i mean
i uh
it's definitely prep it's fantastic uh
idea it is really remarkable that this
d6 move you know it used to be bishop c5
was the main move and the six would be
played by people who are lazy to study
theory but now people play the lines
that used to be played because they were
lazy now they play them still with so
much computer analysis you know this d6
it was supposed to be just you play d6
and then you develop and you just play
and now some kind of forced business
with e takes d4 and then bishop g4 or
some floor stuff out of nowhere i mean
eating is before bishop g4 that is so
weird no that's i mean i haven't i
haven't seen such stuff in
spanish
in this particular
position it's a little bit strange isn't
it
me either and anish i know uh you're
you're joining us i don't know how much
time you got with us but i did want to
get get this in as well again i'm just
referring back to your course which you
which anybody can purchase at
chesable.com
forward slash
[Music]
the role of the chess engine uh if you
could uh
you know you double checked you triple
checked your analysis with the chess
engine and did it cause you
to give up on a line that you really
didn't want to give up on tell us yeah
all the time i mean not in the french in
the french course but in the french
course as well and as well there are uh
constantly these struggles that you have
as a professional that there are certain
positions where you sacrifice for
example some pawns and it looks like you
have compensation and it really has to
work according to your beliefs
because you know you have for example
open files and the better king but the
engine just refuses and then you keep
waiting and trying to make sure the
engine confirms but you know unless the
engine confirms like
eventually um and you try of course to
go very very deep and then you see aya
here it doesn't work because of this and
here it doesn't work because of that
defense and here so there were a couple
of lines yes that um
that the engine would not agree but what
happens more and more often as the
engines get stronger i feel that the
intuition of top grand masters gets
reconfirmed
so the more lines that we felt should be
working and we're not working are
actually working
and
that's and also especially now with the
latest
neural networks
you see that
the latest neural networks are actually
quite uh pessimistic from white's point
of view again
and so more and more variations that we
consider dubious
are uh are liked by them and that's why
you see the rise of you know again this
alekhine is being played the
scandinavian display like somebody
played this affiliate or defense you
know somebody played some scandinavian
with knight c6 all these uh rare
openings they're coming back into
fashion because the latest engines are
saying that well you know they are
having the settings set in such way that
they just give like zero twenty zero
thirty number that is not so high and
professional thinks well okay i can play
it you know so it's quite funny how
professional chess players are
influenced by these engines and these
numbers that are in a way not so
relevant but it's it's good to see the
the way it affects the trends
the
h3 i don't know what it takes and d e
what's the point
well uh by the way thank you very much
for that insight i i i think it's just
remarkable uh the impact
that uh chess uh engines have had well
for sure also i i mentioned that certain
interruption i mentioned peter he's been
around for longer than me analyzing
chess it must have changed like so much
not first he was doing it without
engines then they have come and like at
first they were helping then you were
still helping the engine and now you're
just writing the moves down that the
engines are just pretty much you know
you're just like saying ah this is the
first one you're asking oh can you tell
me why and then you see ah that's why
it's first okay i'll write it down you
know you just you're just writing down
and now the engine is just explaining
you well i think it must have been a
fantastic evolution no throughout the
times
peter absolutely agreed i mean i know
all this evolution i have been part of
right from the
start of the 90s when first fritz
engines appeared and i remember what
kind of impact they had back then and
how you had to work with those engines
and then suddenly later new engines
appeared with ripka there was the big
new development in the middle of 2000s
changing completely the way of thinking
and the way of work you had to readjust
and also what is incredible that like
till 2010 2013 one had the feeling that
okay now we already know what we are
getting from the engines and it's
incredible that in the last couple of i
mean just last few years how much has
changed yeah i mean it would it's so
hard to imagine because before nothing
changed so dramatically as as in the
last one two years yes it's a continuous
uh progress and you always whenever
there is new engine because it is so
much stronger than human you always
think like okay that's
that is like the ultimate truth when
that engine says white is better white
is better and then there comes the next
one which is 50 points stronger and okay
this is a thousand points stronger than
you and now thousand fifty points
stronger than you and then it proves the
other one wrong and you are like ah yeah
yeah so that was wrong this one is right
and then you think okay this is the one
that says the truth so you are always
behind because you are as a human i mean
we have good intuition and we are quite
strong but we are uh much behind uh all
these engines for years already and
their lim i mean the modern engines are
just incredibly strong and also um they
are so much more stylish than the old
engines no they sacrifice material they
play beautifully they don't like bad
bishops apart from the french they're
the bishop is fine but uh they don't
like bad bishops no they don't like bad
pieces they like harmony like the and
it's so good what we really enjoy is
that as humans sometimes our instincts
are being confirmed and then we feel
like okay now we're geniuses you know
our instincts are confirmed
that's our small victory uh by the way
sorry to interrupt just wanted to inform
all of our audience thank you very much
for joining us we are in the fourth game
of today's set hikaru nakamura trails by
one point he must win this game and
sorry guys but i feel already that black
is better just flat out that yeah for
sure for sure for sure i mean uh
honestly when you play knight h2 uh it
cannot be uh like it cannot be that
knight h2 and white is good i mean this
move just isn't it's just knight h2 is a
sign of uh it's a symptom of an illness
yeah i don't mean and i don't mean
obviously hikara i'm in the position
exactly exactly i mean black is just
better and
must must draw i mean that's just
there is no way almost no way that
there's anything going to happen
unfortunately
as much as i would like the intriguing
damage but on the other hand you know
2-2 is also pretty pretty fun you'll see
a long match
why not
right now here because of this move rook
d1 i mean
you're desperate to get in a move like
knight d5 so you open up the bishop and
everything's very very nice but the
problem is that rook d1 is an issue so
your queen being a target i'm thinking
you guys help me out uh first first
thought that came to my mind was a move
like a6 with the idea b5 yeah i
you know so that's a classic no that's
such a class yes sir thank you thank you
very much thank you very much uh you
could go queen b5 and knight d5 but the
moment you said a6 uh peter also
immediately was like oh that's the move
you know
yeah
it's on the board you know
instantly
the class guys seriously it wouldn't
have occurred to me but these classy
players like magnus yasser
very nice very nice very nice okay once
again i'm gonna have to shout out to
luis and satiris to make sure the
players can't hear us guys
[Music]
speak very very soon
queen e2 was also possible no instead of
queen b5 kind of also looked not so bad
also not so bad we need to i liked him
[Music]
black has such a big choice and okay
magnus probably because draw suits him
perfectly he just wants to make the most
sensible who's bringing all his pieces
stabilizing even further let's imagine
placing a black look on d3 that would be
devastating right
yeah and again this knight on h2 is uh
is a sign that things have gone wrong
yeah normally knight is not there it's
somewhere else
yeah somewhere nice it's just somewhere
it's somewhere not necessarily
right
and furthermore you know
the moment that knight on f6
uh finds a square the pawn on b2b no i
mean
you know again
if the match situation was was very
different and magnus needed to win this
game
i would say that uh
winning on demand with black is really
tough and everything else but he was
he's well on his way
drawing this game well
i think uh ikaru unfortunately is on the
war side of that scenario 95 bishop g5
on the board gentlemen
yeah to be fair uh to in encourage
defense i mean we are easy to criticize
but after c5 dc d5 or already after c5
you know against the prepared opponent
and if you win if you need the win he
tried to get a pawn structure that
offers him long-term potential like if
you imagine an end game where your
knight reroutes to e3 and you have let's
say this outside passer
like suppose you trade everything and
you get knight on e3 against the knight
on f6 and you have a rook behind the
queenside pawn and you have like a queen
set majority so he's trying to at least
create a scenario in which he'll be
better i mean i'm sure he understands
that this is not the way to play for
advantage but he's trying to avoid
immediate exchanges and stuff and go for
and sort of go for it but of course if
magnus plays well all these factors like
the knight on h2 and uh
strong knight on d5 they will eventually
tell of course
well also by the way anish i'm just
seeing this move f7 f6 and it seems with
each move they're kind of coming like
hammer blows to white's position uh
f5 next after bishop drops back to d2 i
guess it just it just feels like it's
getting worse and worse peter yeah but
on the other hand i mean f7 f6 is not
entirely the move you you want to play i
mean one of one of my thoughts was that
if i could play knight before here then
i would really love to play it because
you can't play look d8 my queen plus x
on e8 right
and why can't you actually and i and i
didn't find an answer because then next
look dc and abstract everything
it looks fantastic
peter you made a strange
form of of a sentence you started with
like uh if i could but i mean you can no
so just yeah but i i couldn't find an
answer why it's not possible in general
if you cannot find the answer in your
case there is no answer yeah i think
it's just okay thank you very much but
okay we also see that magnus had such a
position that probably he had foreseen
that okay f6 and i'm getting everything
so he didn't really yeah he just he just
missed knight before let's be let's be
honest there uh because f6 is also quite
good i think it's also quite good and
five he just goes for a positional uh
queen king side push
i mean
yeah once again this just uh
this knight in h2 is just but yeah
exactly and they should picture you guys
you know uh since uh since we are here
uh plugging my french course like this
uh nathan h2 you know we never have such
nights in the french defense
no
this is definitely gone wrong in h8 e3
or queen e6 e3 and just uh just by force
you know by force exactly uh
should
ikaru not score in this game it would
mean that we have a tight match and
anish uh
how did you foresee the match before it
started what were your predictions
well there are two types of scenarios so
far in terms of magnus matches now i
feel uh when the matches get close
naturally they they get close and they
remain close but there are also these
scenarios when magnus and it doesn't
matter who his opponent is it can be
fabiano it can be english it can be a
hikaru it can be anyone but when magnus
sort of
crashes crushes through like when he
starts hammering
um
then sometimes you just don't get a
proper match yeah
right
but here we do have the proper margin
once we do and i even had my own
experience sometimes that i would get
the match started on the right foot or
at some point uh strike a counter blow
when you get that then of course it's
different like then he is nervous and
then he is a human again and then you
have your chances
and uh i think in this this match is
definitely the case of hikaru fighting
very well and i think in such a close
match when it's uh two against two
um then i think in car will have his
chances i'm very happy to see that it's
not one of those you know i was afraid
that there could be a 4-0 because you
know sometimes when magnus is playing
well it all comes together his opponents
start to play badly and they collapse
but here hikaru is fighting and i think
in the close match chances are of course
they're never equal imagos always
favorite but i think there are chances
thank you for that i i felt i feel it
very
much the same way and i was worried uh
peter you may remember uh tanya as well
at the very opening well are we going to
see a coronation
or was ding lorraine and the finalists
going to uh you know challenge magnus uh
it's been a challenge and after this
move bishop e1 back to the position it's
bad it's really bad but
magnus has not been able to put away
hikaru that easily but is it really as
bad as it looks anish
uh well you know the question is it as
bad as it looks can only be answered by
the engine i can only tell you how it
looks
it looks bad it looks bad
okay the engine can tell you in terms of
numbers but i saw now uh on the website
yeah it's it's um it's quite negative
what is going on here like it's better
not a surprise not a surprise at all
this almost looks like there's a forcing
variation peter takes on f2 check takes
with the bishop maybe knight c3
looks
like
really bad look
rook takes d8 though here rta
rookie one let's say
knight f3 maybe i'll you know
for some reason i thought i was getting
worse could be worse i think it could be
worse right not e3 was the one i was
also wondering about uh do you have a
strong e3 pawn i like my opponent e3 now
that could be quite a serious asset
good point again in terms of what in
terms of uh in terms of uh
especially playing for a draw with black
that's also not so bad although i have a
feeling that
white is i mean white has definitely
fought his way back yeah i have a
feeling unless i'm missing something
concrete for example queen e4 and queen
and six are not possible because of
rugged her cafe
but e2 is possible no
[Music]
is okay yeah and uh otherwise into
rookie one maybe
and then queen if
or yeah if i just need a drone
yeah yeah yeah yeah you will make that
easily yeah
and anything to be recommended for queen
f6 from the start knight f3 i assumed is
the yeah but i mean e2 like really there
is no like there is no reason not to go
e2 if you can i was trying to put the
queen on f2 ah even even uh you wanted
even better version maybe queen of six
maybe queen e2 i played them
but okay look at these guys yeah e2
played queen takes it to quincy yeah
yeah i mean now anything yeah like queen
takes b5 just right right and just offer
a draw and just uh
celebrate celebrate if you have nothing
to do i mean just to pull up without any
risk of losing right um yeah i think
time to celebrate
rookie come on check wow what
ah okay wow
[Music]
nice
okay that's funny but yeah it's enough
for a win but it's funny though you can
take on d5 like but it's funny
very very professional way peter
professional draw in clinching the set
for magnus
[Music]
yeah absolutely i mean okay but after
this fantastic opening for magnus the
result was never really in doubt it was
obvious that he has everything under
control
and he
didn't know what to do i mean he didn't
know what to try because there was just
nothing position got out of control and
it was
better for black and it was also very
easy to play with black
exactly yeah i think the opening should
not be underestimated also in rapid i
mean more often than not if you really
look closely at games uh you start
realizing that opening still plays a big
role yeah i mean the the one who
gets the opening right controls the game
very often even in the quicker time
control so and tanya you're back with us
we are going to be joined by the world
champion shortly but before that anish
we've got some burning questions from
our audience for you and the first one
is by grand master
alejandra ramirez oh my god no
are you ready for this one i don't know
i'm never ready for a question from
alejandra okay
so ali is asking that i'm a 2570
preparing for the u.s championship
will this french course stand the test
there
completely completely no it's a very
good question in fact uh
i really
try to make sure my course is
understandable to a large number of
people already i saw some review when
someone said that uh
maybe under 1700 is not so easy or
something i don't know i really try to
make it possible to understand for
everyone but that said that said i
wanted to make sure that even if fabiano
you know alejandro's boss
will come across the course uh the
course and if he will uh
uh
you know buy the course and see the uh
all the stuff
he will still not be able to find any
flaws and even peter heinen nielsen you
know the greatest theoretician of all
time also if he downloads my course
he'll also not find any flaws with it so
i really try to make sure it's a
bulletproof but of course you know there
remains i mean alejandro there remain
some strategic dangers with the opening
you know i cannot guarantee you a
victory but uh well as much as possible
theoretically it is sound and yeah you
gotta play well i mean you gotta play
well good luck
right thank you for that and you ale he
recommends it for you as well as for
fabi and we do have the world champion
joining us magnus congratulations
and because anish is here and he hasn't
left yet just quickly magnus what's your
view on the french
[Music]
magnus could i ask you please to just
adjust your microphone
yeah it's a little bit far apart from
you
repeat what you just said if you don't
mind please
oh um just that
the friend i
i mean i agree that the french to be
just
perhaps a little bit more difficult to
play than some others
yeah but if you have right explanations
and a good course that to support you uh
you'll do fine magnus so it's fine it's
fine
congratulations congratulations on your
comeback and i i was still still
thinking you are a favorite even before
today so uh good luck good luck
thank you for joining us all right bye
thank you for that uh
magnus uh a much needed and a very
critical set win today
yeah uh sure obviously after after
yesterday um this was um this was a
must-have
so it only remains to be seen if i can
win
two
sets in a row at some point if
if my math is correct that will give me
until when
uh apologies man the same same issue for
me still i i don't hear you well is it
just some muffled microphone is there
something around your microphone or can
you bring it closer or do something it's
just not so easy for me tanya do you
hear him well
i think he's just fixing it yes okay
okay good sorry for that
we should have him back any moment with
us we're just uh waiting for him to fix
his mic and then we shall be getting
into
uh the critical chess action because the
score is now level and let's give it a
try because i do see magnus is back on
the screen with us
so
magnus can you hear us
yeah sure all right
[Music]
take us through the critical moments
today i think i want to start with game
one because it looked like you started
the day with
with a dream position but it didn't
quite work out
what was going on and where do you think
you you slept in this game
oh that's that's really easy um
there was um there was there was just
one critical moment where i made this
extremely poor move
ab6
um because basically i was i was aiming
for for this and i believe that just ab6
cb6 was was easier but i just missed the
defense rook c8
and um then he's actually completely
fine all of a sudden so ab6 was really
really horrible um and yeah i mean then
afterwards he allowed the trick which he
didn't need to at all um
otherwise i don't think i was really
really that much better um and then i
guess i guess i should have won but he
he fought extremely well and i also
didn't find the key tactics later on
and this move bishop h3 uh you spotted
bishop b6 instantly if he would not go
bishop h3 here but instead player move
like bishop f5 how were you evaluating
your position right about now
um no i again i thought i'd lost all my
advantage basically um
and that it
i mean i guess to some extent it's
easier to play for
for white
because i have somewhat safer king but
i'm in practice i didn't really i didn't
didn't really believe it so um yeah uh
his maneuver
rook
c8
the c7 was just very strong and
right didn't see anything i could do
after that
um
are you going
no as i as i said earlier in the game i
should be winning but
this is one critical moment magnus said
i'm sorry there's a little lag on my
side and
you were saying something
no no
go on
yeah i was just saying that there's one
more moment that i want to ask you about
and this was iran move 31 let me just
bring that up where uh he went g5 here
and we were checking it with the
computer and of course you want your
bishop on did you consider this idea of
going king h2 and bishop g2 immediately
yeah i just missed rook d3
oh right after queen d7 yeah because i
obviously i really really want
the bishop to g2 i just couldn't i
couldn't see away after queen d7
obviously if you know there's a way you
find it in
in a split second but
that's that's the way it goes
but during a game nobody's telling you
that this is the moment sure
and
besides that also
i'd also missed
for whatever reason i i saw that he
could block with his rook when i go to
e7 or eight but i just missed that he
could block
on
d5 as well which was a little bit
upsetting i i suppose in the game i had
excellent winning chances as well but
you it was getting very very difficult
and
i don't really blame myself that much
for
for not finding a win after this
i think that's a really insightful point
magnus that it's when you know that
there's something in a position you know
with when the engines are telling you
that there's some big jump it's sort of
very easy to spot it but it's a
different ball game when you're when
you're playing
oh yeah absolutely but it's um
it's a question of of time as well um
i mean if if i had 10 minutes there or
whatever i would i would think like
um yeah i i need king h2 bishop g2 so
let's try and make it work
right and then
and then then you sort of
sort of find it
but
i mean in hindsight i think
uh 31 h3 was probably a better choice
and
actually i made the exact same mistake
yesterday uh no two days ago in the in
the game that i won in the english that
i played age four against h
instead of h3 in this sort of structure
and it for whatever reason it seems that
h3 is a bit safer
all right and you mentioned about time
now we've seen
we haven't seen you struggle
with the clock in this entire tour but
this final so far we've seen you fall
back on the clock and burn a lot of time
on the clock quite a few times and and
then not have enough of it in critical
moments why do you think that's
happening
um it's because he's he's playing he's
playing well i think
um
i feel like in in uh
all of these tournaments i've in general
been burning a lot of time
um
but especially here he's posting me he's
posing me a lot of problems and there
have been several games here
where i'm thinking i'm gonna win and
then uh i just
i'm just getting faced by my new
problems uh and
[Music]
it's it's a really difficult balancing
act because it's it's so easy to blender
if you just make a couple of quick moves
yeah absolutely it's uh
um
it's a very very difficult format but i
think that's what the tour has been
about to bring out the most challenging
format i want to talk about game three
magnus if you can just uh tell us what
happened here because this was also a
very very exciting game and uh
where do you think it went all wrong for
hikaru in this one
um well
first of all queen f2 was was was just a
shock
because
i i just i just
uh didn't believe that it was possible
um
and then when he played he went rooft8
my first thought was
um
i may have missed some kind of mates
but it turns out he's lost fortunately
um
but yeah that was um
[Music]
um obviously nerve-wracking in the sense
that i'm i'm one move from from getting
mated but
i think it just doesn't work
doesn't work for black at all and he
should have played
rook e5 on
on move 26 which i think would just have
been a fairly straightforward draw
so you mean the line with knight v6 here
yeah i mean i'm a pawn up but it doesn't
matter
right
and after after queen f2 you mentioned
that you felt that you have perhaps
missed something
uh magnus in general we've seen
you have a very confident approach and
not double guess yourself but like
like you're saying at this moment that
this happened do you think this has
something to do with the way how things
have gone so far in this final
um it's been the case uh
in during most of these tournaments
actually um
i think
uh to some extent it's just a healthy
dose of
you know
trying to be trying to be careful uh i
mean if you have time to check you
should check most of the time yes
um but um
but yeah i mean especially especially
now that he's been calculating so well
in this in these matches that
you know at some point um
it starts to be difficult
right and uh magnus uh that's a fair
point now we had we had hikaru with us
yesterday and he was mentioning that
uh you know you you're a favorite coming
into this match and that sort of puts
the ball in your coat puts the pressure
on you and there's also
you know this uh this feeling about when
there's over-the-board chess we always
talk about home ground pressure so you
know we've seen many many
a lot of players top players struggle
with that and with this store having
your name on it feels like the closest
comparison to having some sort of a home
ground pressure do you do you feel that
do you feel there's that it's accurate
to say that there's extra pressure on
you
um
i i don't know i mean i feel like
whenever i i play a tournament i should
should have a very good chance to win it
so
that's
um
obviously i i mean i i love these
tournaments i love the the format and
everything um it's just that yeah it
doesn't does not that much
much extra there's enough to to begin
with
that's a good point especially because
every tournament you do play you go in
as a favorite so that doesn't really
change uh with the format now we're
we've crossed the halfway mark magazine
the score is level two sets to each of
you uh we've spoken about this on the
broadcast that generally a math
situation gives this entire exchange of
information you know you you understand
how your your opponent is playing what
form he's in now going into the final
three sets what's your take away from
how the finals have gone so far
um
first of all i've been i've haven't
found any
semblance of rhythm whatsoever so i'm
very in general very unhappy with the
way i played um today was a lot better
in the sense that he didn't get any
uh
i think any conference chances so today
today was
was an improvement
um
but still there is um there's uh there's
a lot to to work on but i'll i'll at
least i'll um
um
i'll take that with me that today wasn't
wasn't so much about survival as as just
you know bringing the points home from
from good positions
yes uh yes 100
on that uh magnus you
you mentioned about not
struggling a little bit with the rhythm
now everybody has their own way of
dealing with that but for you personally
with your experience when you know that
that's an issue how do you how do you
get yourself in shape or what are the
things that sort of help you
recover from that
well it's it's very very difficult on on
the same
day um i think
um
yeah i i just think when when you
say you just have to
forget all emotions positive or negative
and and just
start fresh i i think there's
there's not
more to say than that um
and yeah just hope for the best
all right well thank you magnus we
really appreciate your time and your
honest insights that you gave just
quickly yes peter any uh any critical
moments that you'd like to discuss oh
for sure tanya i just want to jump in
and say congratulations
magnus i i feel like today
you had
control that it was a more complete day
and your preparation
was simply outstanding
especially for that fourth game where
you know he had to come back he was in a
must-win situation and i think
wow
it was it was quite a performance where
you just shut them down and you took an
advantage right out of the opening um
if you don't mind uh c5 uh very very
impressive move
uh if you could talk about it a bit
please
yeah i i mean i can reveal as much as
that uh c5 was not part of my my
preparation
i i it's just that it's a move
as soon as you see it you know it's
right
uh
and
and yeah i mean i i felt after c5 that
the game was was basically over
um
so that was obviously a very very
pleasant feeling like yeah he he has
he has no development and it's it's it's
clear that he needs to
um to play for equality which he cannot
do in the in
in
view of the match much situation so it's
it's really uh
is
the opening was just a disaster for him
thank you for that and i'll turn it over
to peter
yeah congratulations magnus as well it
was a very impressive day i mean to be
honest uh after the first game i felt
like and i also mentioned the broadcast
i don't know how you will do it not to
go crazy after this missed chance
because i felt like yesterday in the
muslin blitz game you were very close of
winning and this was the next game with
the white pieces which you played so
perfectly you were about to win and let
it slip i felt like maybe it will
influence you today but then you showed
fantastic play how did you overcome this
situation
no it wasn't it wasn't very pleasant but
um
i i was very happy to just get a very
quiet second game
uh i felt like if he wanted to
to kick me while i was down that was
that was the moment
um
and um yeah for for the third game i
just thought now we're playing a mini
match of two and uh let me let me try
another idea in the opening i
uh
at that point i was i was feeling i was
feeling quite okay um and as you said
it's it's just it's an unpleasant
feeling to
to blow such a
certain game but i felt that like as
long as he wasn't creating chances i was
okay
yeah fair enough and one question i mean
this is not
looking like a fantastic strategy
because in the second game you used
bishop d7 and you exactly got what you
wanted from this game too
and you did not burn your idea of which
you used in game four so what is your
take that uh how are you how proud are
you of of these choices
um
i think uh
yeah it was
certainly a
good idea to have uh have in hand i can
i can tell you that um
um yeah i i mean
obviously for for him to to face this
i'm prepared with uh
was uh was quite unpleasant
um so
yeah and it just worked out perfectly
because you know when you played the
move bishop g7 first vivid yasaya almost
got a heart attack that won't know that
this is somehow sleep yeah
but but then we were
i mean very quickly assured that it
seemed like you know what you are doing
yeah
fortunately
all right thank you magnus i will give
back to tanya
i guess just before you leave there is
because you were discussing the opening
from the second game we did have a
question from yan and let's have that up
and i just want to ask you what you have
to say about this wonder if players will
finally draw lessons or simply make
draws this is of course about all the
berlin that we've been seeing
what would you like to say to this
um well he's uh he's the wordsmith that
one
i have nothing to add
all right congratulations on today's win
magnus and we're looking forward to
tomorrow's fight thank you so much for
joining us we really appreciate your
time
thank you
all right so the world champion magnus
carlson levels the math score to 2-2 and
that means we've got three more sets
remaining
and
this final yas and peter we're in for
the long haul for an epic battle and
epic struggle if anybody was thinking
that this was
this was going to be easy for anybody
that's not happening
it certainly isn't tonya i mean the
players are just
thrilling and delighting us
uh i really thought that was insightful
what magnus said to your question uh
peter that game two where where
this decision by
icaru to play d-takes e5 and not kicking
him when he was down because
as you say i mean he missed he missed he
messed it up in a game one uh that was a
that was very telling that was a
psychological moment and a and um hikaru
didn't sense it i want to say that these
world champions they've got this
intuition the sixth sense they know
when you're down
and maybe you don't pick up the fact
that they may be down and
that was maybe key uh peter your
thoughts
yeah i absolutely agree i mean you you
remember i also mentioned before that
what magnus did yesterday made perfect
sense from the match point of view but i
felt like after winning that very first
game with the black pieces he should
have kept on going because hikaru must
have been also in a very bad state of
mind and after that quick draw he gained
back his confidence and got ready for
game three and now i feel very much the
same yeah that the move d takes e5 i did
not like it exactly from this
psychological point of view that
magnus gets the confidence out of it he
already started playing very well i mean
yesterday's last blitz game where he was
about to win
but hikaru escaped then today's first
game he was putting the pressure so it
felt like with the white pieces magnus
is finding more and more to his rear
strengths
and
giving up in this situation the white
pieces so easily
i also felt like this might be a big
mistake
thank you peter and tanya i when you
when you were speaking i i noticed that
the bar been
beneath you
it's turned green there's more green
than white this is a great success for
kiva
not only have we crossed the halfway
mark at the final yes but we've also
crossed the halfway mark of our raising
funds for the community uh through chess
leaving an impact and helping people
recover helping businesses across the
world in isolated communities recover
because as we know that 50 percent of
all premium memberships that are done
during the magnus carlson chester
benefiting kiva final will the proceeds
go to kiva on in their campaign to raise
funds and there is also a 30
off on premium membership so do consider
going premium and especially because it
helps chess 24 continue doing what
they're doing uh bringing such tour to
bringing such a tour to us bringing
these players to us this broadcast to us
the innovative events of banter blitz
and q and a's and all the
all the premium benefits that you get
uh a 30 off on that 50 goes to kiva and
we and there is going to be a price hike
on the membership once the magnus
carlsen tour is over so this is a very
special
finals offer and of course it's not just
that we've been having the best in the
world also doing some educational and
entertaining hot drops as we saw aneesh
giri joining us and talking to us about
his new course on the french the
repertoire which he also recommended
that it's good enough whether you're
playing the us championship or you are
the us champion challenging the world
champion uh it's a solid course so
definitely have a look at that if you
have been wondering how to face
e4 and
with that
i think yes we
it's it's a wrap for us and we are going
to be back tomorrow as the final is
really heating up i think today we saw
magnus come back to his form like he
mentioned himself that the good thing
was that he wasn't struggling we've seen
him struggle in the previous sets but
today was just about bringing the points
home he was getting good positions and
uh he was being able to convert them so
i think a big a very critical set win
and also a big confidence jump for the
world champion in a final that he has
been shaky in but of course hikaru
nakamura has been on his a game and it's
going to be a very very exciting set
tomorrow because whoever wins tomorrow
yes peter
will be super close to the to the final
victory because then you just need one
set and that's immense pressure on the
opponent your final thoughts uh before
we wrap up
well absolutely tanya it's been thrills
and spills galore i just wanted to give
a big shout out to our
audience
thank you so much for sharing your day
with us it really is great to have you
all aboard
um
do take a chance to uh support the
keeper campaign and just let all your
friends know where you're hanging out so
thank you so much and we'll see you all
tomorrow and back over to you peter
yeah thank you yasir one of the things
you know that came to my mind that
magnus as far as i know is a big
favorite of the mba right and they have
all these uh finals of best of seven and
hikaru is the big expert of the nhl
and uh i mean the american spirit with
all these best of seven i wonder whether
this knowledge you know that they are so
familiar they have witnessed so many
great battles does this help them
because you know it's it's not something
that the chess player is really used to
uh facing i mean for me for example this
best of seven i just was very excited
when i heard about it but i would as the
player not know how to approach it but
by giving that all right from the start
i mean it feels to me like these two
players are the real experts of this of
this best of seven and i'm wondering if
it has something to do with this uh this
sport connection
[Music]
an intriguing thought to be sure uh
peter and tanya you get the last word
yeah i just i think i we're all uh it's
been an incredible day of action and as
you said yes peter a big shout out to
our audience to hang out with us for
this uh amazing final that we are
witnessing i think it's just been an
absolute fabulous ride so far and i have
no doubt that the next three sets are
going to be equally
exciting and an absolute block buster
for now check out this new anish giri
blockbuster and we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
no but nobody likes the french i also
didn't like the french but
like the course
makes it great because like it's opening
but with
i've done so much work
to make it actually kind of first of all
correct
like basically correct also like fun i
mean
i'm making like i basically recreate
like i take this crappy french and make
something great out of it
[Applause]
you